Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're live.
James,
what's up?
How are you man?
I'm great.
Don't freak out about your,
your sound of your voice in the
headphones.
This is the first time you ever worn
headphones or a podcast?
Definitely the first time I've heard
myself talk because it weird.
After a second.
Yeah.
That's weird.
You get over it.
Be conscious about it.
Really.
You got to be all right.
You take them off.
You want.
If it's freaking you out too much,
you're going to get through this.
Let's just take this bucket that we
don't need these things.
Just keep this sucker close to you.
So,
uh,
first of all,
thanks for doing this.
You've been on this crazy sort of
whirlwind tour.
Have you gone anywhere or you just been
doing it most from mostly from your
house?
Mostly from my house.
Just on skype.
Now for people who don't know the story,
let's give them the short version of it.
You were working at Google and what
prompted you to write this memo?
Yeah.
So they would have these company wide
meetings where they just push a lot of
this diversity stuff and some of it was
kind of weird.
So I decided to go to these,
uh,
these secret meetings,
sort of that we're about 100 people a
completely unrecorded and they would
talk about some of the things that
they're doing and it would really
contradict what they're saying publicly
where,
oh no,
we're not changing any of our hiring
practices for these candidates.
And they said,
yeah,
we basically are a making it easier for
some kind of ways to get in.
And I,
you know,
I voiced some concerns but people have
just chain me and was like,
no,
you're wrong.
You're just like,
have white male privilege.
I said,
you have white male privilege.
That was the actual word that he is.
Yeah,
there is a lot of that going on.
And so they asked for feedback on the
program.
So I,
I wrote this document to clarify my
thoughts.
I sent it to them,
they looked at it,
but they just ignored it,
never told me anything.
So I went to a couple more of these
programs and you know,
I gave similar feedback,
I gave the same document,
they kept looking at it but just never
said anything and you know,
I would send it to random people that I
knew and half the people will be like,
yes,
exactly.
This is what I've been thinking.
And the other half would maybe disagree
with some points,
but it would never be emotional
outbursts or anything.
It would just be like,
oh,
are you sure that this is actually
happening?
And it's like,
yes,
because,
you know,
I've actually been to these unrecorded
meetings.
This is what's happened.
So if you could get into specifics like
when you're in these meetings and
they're talking about diversity,
what is their concern?
And their,
they're trying to promote an image of
diversity.
Are they trying to promote actual
diversity?
Uh,
do they think that there's a benefit for
diversity or is it a part of their
public public image?
And is it a lot of it to avoid
criticism?
Because I think there's a big issue
with.
I mean,
if you don't have all your bases
covered,
two black women,
two Asian men,
if you don't have all your bases
covered,
you can get like pretty roundly
criticized as not being diverse or being
possibly racist when you do that,
you're kind of fucked.
Yeah.
So Google definitely has a huge target
on its back and so there are people that
want to complain that Oh,
Google is not diverse,
therefore it's racist and sexist.
And so that's a lot of their fear that I
look at their representation and then
compare it to the overall us population
and say,
Oh,
we only have 20 percent women.
We should have 50 percent.
There's obviously some sexism happening.
And so a lot of their stuff is,
oh,
we need to fix this because you know,
all this sexism is bad.
And obviously if you disagree with
sexism,
that's of course bad.
And like I obviously don't want there to
be any sexism,
but I just don't think that that's the
sole cause of this disparity in
representation.
Yeah.
It seems like in the interest of
promoting an image of diversity,
they're willing to bypass science.
And the truth and the reality of
culture,
the reality of human biology and
evolutionary psychology,
there's just so much that they're
willing to look past to get to this one
thing which seems to be like this really
important thing today.
Society that you want to promote an
image of diversity.
It's more important than anything.
So like when you're in these classes or
these,
I mean,
I wouldn't call it a class,
what would you call it?
A meeting,
whatever they are.
Some of them are classes somewhere,
you know,
our day long programs teach you things
like what would they teach you?
They would talk about unconscious bias
and no,
Oh,
lucky you might be racist.
You have to find the racism in you.
And yeah,
there's a whole program that's trying to
retrain your brain to think,
to think about race in a new way or
something.
So they're just assuming you're guilty
pretty much because someone.
Because you're white.
I.
Well,
yeah.
I mean they look at the representation
and say,
racism,
sexism.
Do a black people have to go to this?
I am.
They know one has to have been asked to.
They are definitely pushing it on people
and uh,
now managers are being evaluated by how
well they promote diversity and
inclusion and you know,
it's just a slippery slope and I think
it will eventually become part of our
performance review.
So if you're a white woman,
do you have to go to this?
I mean,
did that,
are you encouraged to go to this?
Are you like,
Hey,
you made it through like this will have
been looking for your fine or if you're
an Indian woman even better,
right?
Is that how it works or would you still
have to go there and approach your
unconscious biases?
Yeah,
they say everyone has these unconscious
bias
even towards white people.
So do they have those
where they have like black people with
their unconscious biases towards white
people?
So they never acknowledged that anyone
could be racist against white people.
Of course.
Why would you.
Yeah.
It's all this.
Like if you have,
you can only be racist if you have power
or sexist if you have power and they
believe that the racist part.
Yeah,
I think so.
Well that's insane.
That's a redefinition.
It's a very recent redefinition of the
term racism,
but it's very slippery,
very dangerous because you could see it
as,
you know,
promoting in fact like exonerating
racism towards other ethnicities or
towards white people were towards people
that you feel like are in a privileged
class.
You'd get away with it because it's no
big deal because they're the ones who
are racist even if it's not even that
person.
If it's people who look like them that
have lived for centuries,
like somehow or another.
Your,
a guilty person just with your white
privilege.
So like what would they tell you when
you would go to these?
Do you do,
did you like express some discontent or.
Yeah,
I didn't.
I,
my main concern was them saying 50
percent in the population look who only
has 20 percent.
And so we're obviously women.
Yeah.
And you know,
there were clear reasons,
at least in my mind that that's not as
simple as they're making out to be and
that there are some differences and that
could explain some of the issues that
women are facing.
And so a lot of these women issues in
tech.
I feel are actually not really gender
issues there.
Just,
uh,
you know,
women on average are more cooperative,
for example,
and so they may find it harder to,
you know,
lean in,
in the corporate world like Sheryl
Sandberg is saying,
but you know,
there are men that also feel like that
I'm not very assertive.
I'm actually pretty shy and so I feel
the same stuff and it's not that,
you know,
there's a ton of sexism.
It's maybe that male typical behavior is
rewarded just as competitiveness is
rewarded in a lot of corporate world,
but it's not that we're just,
Oh,
you're a woman,
therefore you're obviously bad at
coding,
you know.
No one has ever saying that.
Right.
I think there is absolutely an issue
with assertive women being treated very
differently than assertive men.
Like an assertive woman is a bitch.
Like you don't want to be around them.
That's like the,
the,
the bias.
And uh,
that's a real issue I think for women
that want to enter into any sort of a
competitive field.
And you know where a man would be
assertive if a woman does the exact same
thing she's looked down upon or looked
upon like a problem woman or like
someone you don't want to work with,
whereas the guy is just ambitious yet,
although some people will twist that and
say that because I didn't,
a lot of it is just they try to fit
their ideology and they see one data
point and they extrapolate so they see
these studies and it's true that these
women are viewed as less
likable,
but they are seen as just as competent
and so their performance reviewed isn't
affected really by being assertive.
It's just that socially they may not be
as well.
Right.
But then it's got to be a factor in the
way they behave because for men,
a ball busting successful man is
supposed to be like looked up to like,
oh,
this is the guy who was kicking ass in
the corporate world.
He's doing it right.
Like,
you know,
bob is ruthless.
But if Jenny's ruthless,
like you don't want to be around her,
you know,
it's a,
it's a weird.
It's just,
that's,
I feel like if there is a real bias with
men who,
obviously I don't work in tech,
but I would assume that that would be a
real bias.
Yeah,
and I mean I think some of the solution
to that is just allowing people to be
more cooperative and you know,
actually,
so for example,
a google,
you're really rewarded for owning a
particular project and seeing that one
project go through,
but if you're someone that is just,
you know,
can really help a lot of different
people and you're not necessarily the
sole owner of any individual thing,
but you're,
you provide a lot of value to the
company that isn't really seen as
positive as someone that really drove
the project alone.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
that seems like a bad thing for
teamwork,
right?
Is that just a bad philosophy or
something that got stuck in the way the
system works?
Sure.
I think it's sorta just,
it's hard to evaluate if I did,
you know,
10 percent of my time on 10 different
projects and I help them.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
So you'd have to essentially trust the
workers instincts and work ethic and now
the blow back from this has been very
intriguing,
you know,
as an outsider looking at it from the.
When I first heard about it,
you know,
I thought,
well,
this mean angry man must have written
some things saying that women's suck at
tech or they suck at this and you know,
and people were reacting to this blatant
misogynistic tribe that are ascribed
that I,
uh,
was,
was hearing about what,
when I read it I was so confused because
I was like,
where's the mean stuff?
Like where is this?
And you also think that the other thing
that was really confusing was it some
people were reprinting it without
citations.
Did that freak you out?
Like when you're being misrepresented?
Yeah.
Especially when people would say,
oh,
it was so unscientific because it didn't
have citations.
And that was their entire argument.
Who did it?
Who printed it with outside citations?
Because some major publications
republished it yet I think it was
Gizmodo or motherboard or something
like,
why the fuck would they do that without
citations?
That seems so unfair.
Unreasonable and so irresponsible.
I think a lot of these companies just
have certain narrative that they're
trying to push.
Yeah.
And so like even,
you know,
I've tried to talk to a lot of these
reporters and I'll give hour long
interviews with some of them and at the
end they'll just write the same sort of
article of like,
Oh yeah,
he's just a misogynist.
And so I think even if I can convince
the individual journalists,
they are under pressure by their boss to
write a certain type of article,
what a weird world we're in right now
when it comes to that,
because I was looking for something that
could be,
could be like
evidence of massage.
The only thing that I could find,
and this is a very mild criticism,
is that you were saying,
I believe you used the term neurotic,
that women were more likely to be
neurotic.
Neuroticism.
Yeah.
That's one where a lot of women go,
well fuck this guy.
That's it.
That's all.
I mean,
what'd you base that on?
Yes.
So at there's the psychological big five
personality traits and neuroticism is
just one of them,
right?
That's the actual term that they use and
it's sort of unfortunate that that's the
term.
Yeah.
It's that one.
I feel like maybe you could have danced
around that,
but that's it.
I think it's just I was too much into
the,
like I've seen the word so often that I
didn't really associate it with neurotic
and negative connotations.
Yeah.
Well I've seen a bunch of your
conversations.
I've listened to you talk to Ben Shapiro
and a couple other folks and uh,
you know,
your thought process is very reasonable
and very wealth sorted out.
And another thing that I'm not hearing
from anybody is how you wrote a whole
page and a half describing all the
different ways that women could be more
involved in tech or you can encourage
more women to tackle like,
this is not the work of a massage test.
This is the work of someone who is
carefully considering an issue and
looking at it from a very.
What I felt like,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
but that you felt frustrated that you
were looking at something that was a,
that people,
the way they're approaching this wasn't.
They weren't looking at it for what it
was.
They had kind of decided how they were
going to describe it and how they were
going to deal with it and it wasn't
really based on facts or reality and
certainly not on science and you sort of
felt frustrated by this and you decided
to try to interject with as much of the
current science as you could that could
possibly explain choices.
Not why women are bad at it.
Not why were they,
why they shouldn't be in it,
which is what I kept reading,
but more that why women choose to go
into certain professions.
What could be the impediment and what we
could do to maybe encourage more women
to do it.
Instead of doing this sort of a blanket
style diversity where you're just like,
oh,
we need two of these and we do two of
those.
Which is what I.
I seem to think that they were doing.
Is that,
is that a good assessment?
Yeah.
By the way,
this will never trend on youtube.
You might get $5 million hits.
It'll.
I mean that's a real problem too.
Like there's a lot of censorship when it
comes to these sort of conversations.
Like they would rather look at me who
looks like a meathead and look at you
and go,
oh well these fucking guys are just
talking shit about women for an hour.
Right?
I mean,
do you feel that?
Definitely.
And you'll be labeled right now
I've already been labeled.
All right.
Doesn't matter how many left wing
positions I support.
I look all right.
Which is obviously like sexist,
Short,
misogynist,
racist,
all that stuff.
Yeah.
Well,
but I mean just labeling us because
we're white man or something.
A certain label because it's.
Yeah,
it's prejudice.
I mean it really is,
but people don't mind prejudices in that
regard.
You know,
they only like,
they don't,
they have an issue with prejudices when
it comes to what they feel like are
disenfranchised or marginalized people.
But white people,
fuck them.
You know,
he can't,
you know,
that's the thought process,
right?
You can't be racist towards white
people.
So like what are the most egregious
things like one of the most ridiculous
things that they were trying to push
when you were at these classes or
meetings.
So I mean besides the fact of just
certain things in our hiring process
that would favor certain people which
would create negative stereotypes for
people just in general.
So I,
one thing about stereotypes that they
don't realize is that people will
automatically create stereotypes no
matter what and it's based on their
environment.
So we see this with affirmative action
to in academia where if you create a
sort of situation where people have
portions of the population are
performing differently,
then you'll automatically create the
stereotype that Oh,
maybe all the Asians are smart and all
of the other minorities aren't as smart
in this college.
Right?
Because you needed a 1600 to get in if
you're Asian and you need lower
otherwise.
And so you'll automatically create that
stereotype.
And that's negative for everyone because
you know,
it creates this tension between the
groups and they self segregate because
of that,
while if you just put everyone in the
same level,
then they'll just intermingle and it'll
be great.
And so,
you know,
that has its negative consequences and
it may be illegal,
which is what I was trying to say in my
document.
So that aspect I think is bad.
But then also,
you know,
once you think that,
oh,
all of this is because of sexism and
even though we can't really see overt
signs of sexism,
like,
Oh yeah,
you're a woman,
therefore you are bad and no one is
saying these sexist slurs or then it
must be some low level bias that we all
have and that's why they're pushing all
this unconscious bias and
microaggressions and just increasing
every one sensitivity to,
oh you said something that could be
interpreted in this one weird way and
that might offend someone somewhere.
Therefore you should never say anything.
And it's really stifling.
Well,
I think we would all agree that we would
all be better off if we treated people
nicer.
If we,
if we didn't have racism,
if we didn't have sexism,
we just appreciate it.
People for their qualities and just
could be very objective about that.
Um,
but when you're,
I would imagine that when you're running
a company as large as something like
Google,
you kind of have to put fires out before
you even see smoke and like the
writing's on the wall when it comes to
criticism today and anything that,
that people can point to when it,
when it's,
whether it's,
um,
a percentage of women,
the percentage of minorities,
whatever it is,
where that they feel like is off.
I mean,
people will write articles about this.
It can damage your stock profile,
right?
I mean it can,
it can,
like companies can take a hit on the
stock market because of an article that
someone could write about a lack of
diversity.
Like,
oh Geez,
they all lack of diversity.
Like that's a real issue.
Yeah.
And there have been reports of companies
that'll have these diversity programs.
And then blackmail companies,
if they don't take them,
so say you know,
they'll start complaining because you
know,
all of these companies are the same and
that they have about 20 to 30 percent
women so they could do the same attack
against anyone.
And so they blackmail,
accompany,
say,
Oh,
you need to do these certain programs
and if you don't then we'll start doing
external pressure on you.
So who are the companies that are
blackmailing them for the groups?
At least from what I've heard.
And this is all secondhand.
It's uh,
a lot of the programs that.
So they'll hire contractors to perform
some of the diversity programs.
Oh.
So they have like,
sort of like Jesse Jackson,
you should do with the rainbow
coalition.
You know,
the story behind that.
A little.
This is the,
uh,
second secondhand story.
But the second hand store was that he
would go into these groups and uh,
if anybody had said something,
uh,
whatever reason they had to get into
this company,
they would go into this company and then
they would charge them a tremendous
amount of money to go in and create
these diversity programs.
And if they didn't do that then they
would shame the company and they will
claim the company was racist.
Know Jesse Jackson had like this laundry
list of things you wanted,
like jumbo shrimp cocktail and all this
crazy shit and live I'll ride.
But really like it's been kind of
documented,
you know,
I mean I'd have to go back over it
again.
I remember it only barely,
but the,
I
mean that's where he got that moniker
race pimp that will,
he was essentially doing was race
pimping and then he was going around and
you know,
kind of threatening people that we will
call you a racist,
we'll call your company racist,
comply in this manner.
And
that.
That's scary.
Yeah.
And I mean I see that a lot at google.
Not necessarily,
you know,
the same threatening,
but just people feel that they have to
walk on eggshells,
otherwise they'll get reported to hr by
some random activists within the company
because you have activists in the
company.
Yeah.
And you know,
that was sort of made public,
uh,
you know,
with all of this where there were some
people that just really pushed and
started complaining a ton based on my
document.
They would email my hr,
everyone up my management chain and
they'd write all these posts and try to
coordinate people to really shamed me.
And then they started tweeting about it
after and that's how it leaked
externally.
Woo.
What was the criticism of the memo?
Like did anything make sense?
Did anything make you go,
hmm,
I could have worded that better.
I obviously the neuroticism.
Yeah.
I,
I could have worded that differently.
the fact that I didn't talk about all
the biases are that are against women as
much,
but it was really that this was in
google internal document and so we
already have so much stuff about the
potential biases against women.
And this was just the other side of the
story,
the other perspective that wasn't being
heard.
So yeah,
I,
I don't really know any criticism that
was really.
Oh yeah,
that was definitely.
I should have done that
man.
I'm so how you would put this memo out
there and then the memo got leaked and
then once it got leak you got fired.
Yeah.
As soon after.
But they knew about the memo already.
Right.
So.
And they were cool with it.
Like how long had the memo had been
floating around?
About a month.
Wow.
So as soon as it went public,
like yikes.
Get rid of them.
Yeah.
Wow.
It was,
it seemed to just be a PR thing.
Of course.
Yeah.
But it's also a,
it's weak,
you know,
and it's like,
it's really disturbing that someone
couldn't look at this for what it really
is like this is an opportunity to have a
discussion about the subject,
you know what I mean?
Here's this very detailed thing.
If you guys disagree with it,
let's debate it.
Let's talk about it.
Like I said,
the only thing that I thought was even
remotely derogatory was that one word or
that one idea that women are more prone
to neuroticism.
Other than that,
it just seemed to me to be evolutionary
psychology.
It seemed to be like a lot of stuff that
has already been really well researched
and this is some pretty clear
differences and again,
it's not all women or all men,
but there's a tremendous amount of
evidence that shows that males lean
towards certain professions and females
lead towards other professions.
Yeah,
and these are based on surveys of like
half a million people,
so people are saying,
Oh yeah,
this is just one study of the child is
like,
no,
it's 90 different studies across many
different countries and you know,
there have been even experiments that
length this to just prenatal
testosterone.
Yeah.
Which is pretty strong evidence that
there's some biological link.
We're all also,
if you have a company like Google,
which by the way,
before we go any further,
I'm a big fan of Google use their
products all the time.
I have a google phone.
I mean,
I think they're amazing.
I think that browser is excellent.
Uh,
I like,
I use chrome,
I think they kick ass every morning.
I go to my phone and I check the google
news.
I have a whole setup,
but that's one of the first things I do.
I check the news on my phone from
Google,
so it's not like I'm an google person,
but
if,
if
there wasn't some sort of evolutionary
psychology reason or some sort of a
prenatal testosterone reason or some
biological reason why people were
inclined to choose one profession over
another,
google would have to be a fucking
horrible company.
If everything was.
Even if everybody was 50 slash 50 and
they're only hiring 20 percent women,
that means they're monsters.
They're suppressing 30 percent of the
weather.
They're just like,
fuck you,
you can't work here.
You can't get hired.
You're just as good as us,
but fuck off is a man's club.
They would have to be monsters.
Yeah.
And that's why I feel like some people
are shaming me.
Like,
oh,
this is such a bad thing to tell little
girls that are interested in technology
when really I think this is a much
better view of the world where it just
you,
yeah.
If you're interested in technology,
great.
There aren't as many women my queue,
but if you are,
that's amazing.
While the other side of the story is,
oh no,
even if you are,
then you'll find face all these
challenges and it'll just be an uphill
battle against sexism and you'll never
be seen as good as a man and you know
that's not very encouraging to a lot of
people.
Well,
it sounds so not.
It's not necessarily accurate.
You're kind of like bending the truth to
meet your narrative.
You know,
where instead we should maybe look at
what are the differences between men and
women,
but that's the thing people don't want
to even accept.
There's a trend today to not accept
biological differences between the
sexes,
which is just fucking bananas.
Like let's just not.
Let's not accept the fact that water
gets your wet.
It's just weird.
It's weird when people ignore truth to
fit their ideology and when you're
looking at like just sheer numbers of
people,
all you have is these numbers.
I mean you could have a bunch of reasons
why,
but to say that the only reasons our
implicit biases that the only reason
this is some sort of discrimination
against women,
that's the only reason why they're not
50 slash 50.
That's crazy.
That means we're monsters,
right?
I mean,
doesn't it mean more monsters?
That means all men are monsters.
Yeah.
When it's often the exact opposite,
you know,
we're very welcoming of women.
We really want every woman that we can
get and you,
they'll even twist these studies that
they have where they'll do these large
analyses of,
Oh,
why did you leave tech?
And it will be broken down by men and
white men and it'll show a 30 percent of
women felt like there was unfair
treatment and harassment and then a one
in 10 women felt like there was undue
sexual attention to them and then the
media will just report on that.
But they don't see that 40 percent of
men compared to 30 percent of women felt
like there was a unfair trade,
men or harassment and then one in 12 men
felt like there was a,
you know,
unwanted sexual attention.
So,
you know,
they completely disregard the other side
of the narrative that,
you know,
it's not really a gender issue,
that there's just unfair treatment in
general,
you know?
Well I think men are gross.
I wouldn't want to work with them in an
office.
I mean if I was a woman I would think
that would be the worst place to work
because in an office with men,
especially if I was attractive and it
was just around a bunch of goons or
staring at my butt and just saying
stupid shit.
Men are gross.
I mean I think like generally is an
issue with men and women working
together because a lot of men are gross.
You know?
I mean it's not all of us obviously,
but I mean just if I want to be honest
about it,
I would say that men,
I think women probably have to deal with
a lot of shit.
But is that the reason why only 20
percent of them are in tech because
that's not the case with all jobs where
they work together and I think men are
gross across the board.
They're not just growth in tech.
I mean they're probably grows like what
our jobs were.
Women are disproportionately
represented.
I'm like on the other side,
like is it like a healthcare center?
Nursing veterinarians schools.
So a lot of things that deal with people
or animals in this case.
Yeah.
Well I bet they deal with gross dudes
there too here.
But that doesn't stop them from being
hired at a disproportionally favorable
number percentage.
Yeah.
It's um,
we got to look a,
I think collectively.
Here's one good thing.
Here's the good thing about Google
because I don't want to trash on Google.
And the good thing about tech companies
in general,
I feel like we are in a way better
position that tech companies are leaning
way left.
I think we're in a way better position
socially that tech companies are being
extremely concerned about diversity
because you just don't feel that.
And a lot of companies where they are
about the hard line there about the
bottom line,
making money,
kicking ass,
taking names,
pushing the company ahead.
And they're,
they're,
they're about,
you know,
infinite growth.
This is not what I see from tech
companies.
What I see from tech companies is
extreme caution when it comes to social
issues and this extreme desire to be
thought of as being very diverse,
very fair,
very liberal.
I think that's good.
I really do.
I think it balances it out.
And I also think when I think at least
about the smartest people in the world
or the most innovative people in the
world today,
I almost always think about tech because
I think about like,
well you look,
if you looked at the human organism,
you can look at the human organism,
the human species as a whole.
And if you looked at like what does it
do that's most impressive?
Well,
what is does is his constant innovation
and this constant desire to make things
more and more efficient,
faster,
more capable that that's a big part of
that is tech.
So the people that are like in a lot of
ways,
at least the most technically creative,
those people are oftentimes very left
wing and very liberal.
So I liked the fact that Google has this
as a thought process.
I just wish that it was unbiased in its
determinations when it comes to biases.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So I agree that being progressive isn't
necessarily a bad thing and you know,
I,
it is great that Google has this don't
be evil motto and you know,
they've decided,
oh yeah,
we get a ton of ad revenue,
therefore we can do a ton of random
stuff that's good for the world and
shit.
But you know,
I think unfortunately there are
political bias has created yet they've,
they haven't forgotten their don't be
evil motto.
It's just that don't be evil has turned
into just don't disagree with us and
what our ideology says they got sloppy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well they're just a little off,
but they're going the right way,
you know,
and look,
it's very difficult to fucking.
I mean,
how could you run a giant company like
that and be just totally cool and above
ground and have it all worked out?
I mean,
it just doesn't happen.
You know,
and especially when you have all these
internal influences,
like you're talking with these activists
that work,
that have,
they have a vested interest in proving
that there's racism,
there's a vested interest,
like when you go looking for a,
uh,
you know,
if you have a hammer,
everything becomes an issue,
right?
If you're a person who's the type of
person that's looking for racism
everywhere,
fuck man.
You're going to find it in all these
weird places.
So like that.
Don't even make sense.
Like these hidden unconscious biases
where you have to examine yourself.
Don't just look at overt actions and see
whether or not those actions or racism.
Yep.
Racist.
You have to actually examine all your
thoughts and try to find racist thoughts
and because they are in there,
whether you want to believe it or not,
right?
Oh,
Jesus isn't.
God damn goes ton.
You know,
this is a witch hunt
[inaudible].
It's like,
it's not.
I like,
again,
even though I'm a white man,
I really feel like it's leaning better
that we're shitting on white men.
Then,
you know,
if it was the other way,
if we were shitting on minorities,
I mean it would be very disturbing if an
enormous company like Google was going,
well let's just,
let's be honest.
Puerto Ricans are lazy.
Know,
like,
Whoa,
but if a company comes along like
Google,
it's like,
well,
you know,
white,
you can't be racist towards white
people.
Like,
okay,
like least we can work here.
We could talk,
we can talk about this,
but this is,
you're saying something fucking crazy
racist.
I know you don't think it's crazy and
racist because you're trying so hard to
not be racist towards minorities that
you're looking at what's a temporary
majority?
I mean white people only majority for
another decade.
Right?
You know,
I hope it evens out,
but I feel like in defense of Google,
it's better to be leaning incorrectly in
that direction
than to go the other way.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think it's fine to have a leaning.
It's just you need to not be blind to
the other side and I think that that's
what's happening right now.
Yeah.
Where you know,
they're completely shutting down the
conversation and they're really making
certain employees feel completely
alienated.
Well,
yeah.
It seems like you can't,
obviously you tried to talk about it and
you were fired.
Yeah.
No,
I mean you were,
you were shamed for a little while and
then it went public and then you were
fired.
Now why did,
did they do,
did they send it publicly because they
knew that people would have a negative
reaction towards it?
That's what I think.
Yeah.
I didn't know who did it.
It was probably the people that were
tweeting about it and saying that I was
just a massage and it's Nazi person.
I don't see.
Yeah,
I definitely used white supremacists.
Nazi was used.
Yeah.
They just keep escalating and at some
point I don't really know it'll happen.
You know,
white supremacists is now being used for
a lot of things.
You're a white supremacist somehow.
Wow.
And at some point people will just see
no,
these people aren't actually that and
you know,
they've just create a bubble of words
that they say and it just keeps getting
more and more extreme and at some point
it'll just shatter like an economic
bubble,
but I,
but that's very dangerous because it
opens a door to competition to google,
like someone who is more rational.
And I think that's unfortunate for
google to like to be supporting these
ridiculous ideas.
Like I've read this one article with
this woman was calling you a misogynist
and uh,
it was like a,
she was
being really brutal,
but it was,
it was a total false narrative because I
was listening,
I was reading it and I was trying to,
like,
I'd read your memo.
So I read your memo and then I read this
article about your memo.
I'm like,
this is like an angry person that has
just decided that this is the focus of
all the woes of the world is James and
I'm going to shit on James and the
massages the world.
Like James are the reason why women
can't excel in tech.
Yeah.
And I think part of that is that there's
just an asymmetry,
so there's no punishment for writing
this really angry letter that says how
misogynist I am,
even though that's a negative to me and
anyone else that has similar viewpoints.
So there really needs to be some sort of
retribution maybe for people that just
so openly are so negative,
you could just get away with it.
Yeah.
And then no one questions it.
It's not open for debate.
That's really part of the problem.
It's like people are so looking for
things to be racist that when someone
cries racism,
if you debate it at all,
like,
well how is he racist?
Like you become a Nazi for like
discussing things.
Even if you,
even if you just objective go over the
facts and don't agree with their
assessment,
you become a racist.
Yeah.
And you know,
even if you don't say anything that's
overtly racist,
they'll say,
oh yeah,
that's just dog whistling and Oh yeah,
you can tell what he meant when he said
sad.
The could see it in his eyes.
This is I,
this is not hyperbole what I'm going to
say.
But this is real.
This is how mccarthyism got started.
This is how it got started.
Everyone was looking for communists and
every.
You couldn't even explore what communism
was like.
You couldn't be confused.
Like if I read a book today,
like I've got a book over there by
Michael Malice on North Korea.
If I read a book on North Korea like,
well what's what's going on in North
Korea?
People wouldn't be like Joe Rogan's a
North Korean supporter.
He wants to move to North Korea.
He wants us all to be under a communist
dictatorship wrong by Kim Jong Moon.
He was like,
you wouldn't say that,
right?
Well,
back then you would.
Back then during the mccarthy era,
it gives you started reading like
communist newsletters or you started
going to a meeting,
like what?
What is this all about?
You could get shamed run out of
Hollywood,
and it was a giant issue and people were
ratting on people and they were doing it
for the same reasons.
They did not want to be lumped in with
this group,
so they would immediately turn people
down.
They were turning in.
Their neighbors were like scary time
where people were looking for the
communists.
Everybody's looking for the dirty red
scare,
you know,
they're going to come and infiltrate our
world.
It's very similar because it's,
it's a mindset,
this,
uh,
um,
this mindset of not looking at things
objectively but having everything boxed
into these very convenient packages and
this is one of them,
that diversity is of the utmost
importance and that anything that does
not challenge that idea or anything that
does not support that idea rather is
racist.
Yeah.
And that was sort of what I was trying
to say when I said demoralized diversity
because,
you know,
we've just put on such a pedestal and
we've stopped looking at the costs and
benefits of it and we've just started
looking for villains,
you know,
all the racists and we just want to
punish those villains and an label.
Anyone that disagrees with any of the
precepts of diversity as some sort of
evil person.
Well,
it just sort of foolish approach,
especially the approach of making Asian
people get higher scores that is so
racist.
Like,
yeah,
they study harder and do better.
What's the reason?
I don't know,
whatever the reason is they do it.
I mean,
is it cultural?
Probably.
Is it a biological.
I don't know what,
but whatever reason it is the correct
response that is not make Asians get
higher scores.
That's fucking insane.
Super Racist.
You know?
I mean how racist is that?
That's crazy.
Like why are they.
I mean and there are minority which is
even weirder,
but it's somehow or another that one is
like we let that one slide because we
know they,
they don't complain and they kick ass
and they'd go and study hard.
So for some reason we like let that one
slip.
Yeah.
And a lot of this has some really
nefarious history were the beginnings of
just,
you know,
we used to just have tests and then that
would be how you got into Harvard for
example,
and whoever has the highest score we get
in,
but then they saw,
oh there's too many Jewish people
getting in.
And so they started adding all this,
oh,
let's look at your extra curriculars and
let's make it more subjective on who we
get in and that,
that way they could discriminate against
Jewish people.
Really.
So that's how it started.
Yeah.
And this was like early 1900.
Wow.
Well yeah,
there's another one.
There's a,
there's a disproportion amount of
European Jews that are Nobel prize
winners.
Right?
Why?
Well,
they're fucking smart.
Like what?
What does,
what does that mean?
Does that mean that we're,
we're prejudice against Irish people
know what does it mean?
Well,
what it,
whatever it means.
The end result is what's significant.
We're not stopping other people from
taking these tests.
Right.
If you get a disproportion amount,
portion amount of European Jews,
there should be some sort of study in.
There has been.
But there should be some sort of studies
as to what is it culturally like,
what is it?
What is the significance?
Like what,
what has happened in the past that led
this one group of people to be
extraordinary,
successful,
extraordinarily successful in one area.
Well that's what we should study.
We should try to keep Jewish people out.
That's fucking insane.
And it's racist and I think Asian people
are not complaining the same way other
folks would know with the same exact
issue.
You know?
I mean,
it's essentially a reverse affirmative
action sort of a situation.
Really Weird.
Yeah.
It's unfortunate.
I mean,
especially since many of these are just
first generation immigrants,
they don't feel like they necessarily
have the power to really stand up to
some of this.
Do you,
uh,
have any very Asian friends?
Have you ever been around like really
strict Asian households?
Yeah,
the culture is definitely different and
there is a higher priority on school and
more traditional values.
I had a good buddy of mine when I was
young who was Korean and he was in
medical school and his parents were
Burger udl.
I mean they just wanted a's across the
board.
No fucking excuses.
You will study until your hands bleed
and you know,
there was just this sort of culture of
success in that household and have work
hard work and hard work ethic.
And you know,
the family's idea was like,
look,
we came over to America from South Korea
so that you could kick ass,
period.
You're not going to come over here and
fuck off.
And obviously he was a fucking straight
a student and a,
just a wizard.
I mean this dude was just always awesome
at everything and always working really
hard.
But he was completely stressed out all
the time and everything.
And he's like,
but just getting everything done.
But I mean it's the culture that he grew
up in.
So to discriminate against that guy and
say,
well you work too hard.
Yeah,
junk shit.
You can't,
you know,
your scores are a little bit too high.
You don't like it.
So we're gonna we're gonna need a higher
threshold for you.
That's racist.
Yeah.
And there's nothing that they can do.
You can't work harder and know.
No,
it's stupid.
It's like saying to athletes like
certain athletes so,
well,
you know,
you've been training too hard and so
we're going to need a faster 40 yard
dash from you than a regular person to
get on the team.
He would never say that.
You would say,
well,
this guy is obviously super dedicated
and gifted.
This is the guy we want our team.
And that's the one thing where I feel
like we don't see a lot of this stuff.
You know,
uh,
we,
we like results when it comes to
athletics.
When it comes to things like,
what's your number?
Like,
what is the fastest you can run?
What is,
how high can you jump?
What's the pole vault that you do,
you know,
how far do you throw a disc?
Is all those things like very clear,
very clear numbers.
You can't,
you can do that sort of same sort of
approach that you're dealing with
academics or with industry.
You can't do that approach.
When it comes to athletics,
[inaudible],
it's,
I mean,
I'm not suggesting that the whole world
is a sport,
but I mean when,
when it comes to things like scores and
keeping people out and letting people in
and trying to push to get more people of
a certain color ethnicity and like
you're,
you know,
doing some slippery work,
man,
you know that it gets real weird when
you start doing that.
Yeah,
I,
it's all about leveling the outcomes of
people and yet I think there's this
scary,
a Kurt vonnegut short story where if
you're a really smart,
then you'll have to wear headphones that
just beep all the time.
If you're a beautiful,
you'll have to wear a mask in the future
if you're strong and you'll have to have
all of these weights on you.
You know,
it's
sort of getting there.
It's the same sort of ideology and it's
scary.
Well,
life is not fair,
right?
It is just not.
No one wants to hear that and this is
really the core issue for all of this
stuff.
Life is not fair.
There are people that are so much
fucking smarter than me when I talked to
them,
I feel like some sort of a monkey,
you know,
just just,
there's no getting around that.
There are people that are so much bigger
than me,
but then I stand next to them.
I feel like a child,
you know,
there's just no getting around that,
that that's just the way of the world
and I think the key is,
I mean,
I guess with a company is to try to
figure out how to manage all of these
unfair aspects of being a biological
entity and the civilization.
And I don't think Google is doing the
right job by firing you for promoting
science because that's what you're
doing.
You know,
I had a friend who actually was
comparing what you did to,
what's that term friend knology when you
study the size of people's heads.
When they got there.
And I was like,
man,
you can't say that.
It's not what he's doing.
He's doing because he's not saying that
women can't do it.
He's not saying they wouldn't be better
at it.
He's simply using science and citations
to describe many of the issues that
probably led to people choosing what
they choose to do for a career.
Right.
But you can't do that,
man.
Look,
look at you.
You're here.
You're everywhere.
You're talking about this.
Yeah.
I mean hopefully people will start
seeing that at least how much the media
was misrepresenting it.
Yeah.
Did you feel frustrated by all these
articles?
I mean,
it's got to be weird to have people call
you a white supremacist and a Nazi and.
Yeah,
and they also try to dig up any dirt
that they can find on my history and
stuff.
Way Back in high school that I might've
done tomb raider it as war Croft.
He was a girl running big tits.
Did they find anything?
Not really.
Damn,
dude.
What if you had like some dark secret?
Yeah.
That's the thing.
Like I could have done some random thing
that was bad of course,
but I mean that wouldn't change the fact
that what I wrote wasn't the sexist
thing.
Right.
If you did something horrible in the
past,
at least people can go,
oh,
okay,
maybe this guy's a bullshit artist,
and he leaned this stuff toward sexism
even though there is some science behind
it.
What he wrote was biased,
but I haven't seen a legit criticism of
the actual work itself.
I really haven't.
I've,
I've read a lot of stuff on you,
man.
It's a little creepy.
I haven't seen anything that made sense.
Everything that was criticizing,
criticizing you was being really
dishonest.
Yeah.
It was either just,
Oh yeah,
this is obviously misogynist,
or they would attack claims that I
didn't make.
They were like,
Oh yeah,
we've shown that women are better in
school and are doing better in math.
Yeah.
It's like,
okay,
I wasn't talking about that at all.
Yeah.
It does nothing to do with career paths,
you know?
Um,
was really fascinating to
me that the woman who's the CEO of
Youtube responded and said it hurt her
and she read your memo and I'm like,
you're the CEO of Youtube.
You won.
You're the winner of winters when it
comes to ut,
like you're the head of tech,
like no one's saying you don't exist
saying you can't do it.
You obviously did it.
You're a fucking running the thing.
This is crazy.
Why did it hurt?
Science hurts.
What hurts?
Like,
look,
there are,
there's,
there's outliers,
right?
There's always going to be interesting
to find out why straight white males
choose different career paths.
Like why?
I mean,
there's so much variation.
There's so much.
So many variables.
There's so much difference.
There's people that are um,
you know,
there's women that are mma fighters.
Like why?
Why are they doing that?
Like,
what is it?
I don't know.
Like there's,
there's women that are race car drivers.
There's like,
there's outliers.
Does that mean that we need a exact
representation of males to females in
mma?
Well,
that's insane.
That's not going to happen.
For whatever reason.
Is that the state with that Nascar,
it's not going to happen.
There's not some implicit bias.
It's keeping women from driving 250
miles an hour.
I don't know what it is,
but I don't think that's it.
I think there's probably some biological
differences between men and women and
they vary.
There's a spectrum,
you know,
for Nascar it's likely,
risk aversion.
Yeah.
And some stuff related to that.
Same with MMA.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean I wouldn't want.
Yeah,
I mean look at it and I want to do it,
you know,
and I know a lot of pretty girls that
are doing it.
It's very weird.
So it's,
look there's people make choices,
you know,
some people choose to get their bodies
tattooed,
some people choose to do all sorts of
strange things,
you know,
it's,
I don't know why they do what they do,
but it's interesting to study them and
it seems to me that all you were doing
was talking about your own personal
frustration with this very narrow minded
approach to diversity.
Right.
And you know,
they never even say what exactly I could
have done differently to not do this.
And you know,
there was actually a great piece in the
Atlantic or something that was directed
at Sundar is like,
okay,
what specific parts of the document
we're against the code of conduct and
what parts are free to discuss and what
are not.
Because right now you can't discuss
anything,
you know,
he just said,
Oh yeah,
this document is invalid.
And so it means that no one can bring up
any of these issues now.
And just they just have to walk on these
really vague eggshells when really if
they said no,
this specific part is unacceptable and
everything else is fine,
then at least there will be some wiggle
room and people would know what the
rules are.
But.
And we see this a lot with Google policy
where they had these like no jerk
policies and no jerk.
Yeah.
Like don't be a jerk.
Okay.
And were jerk is totally up to them to
define.
And so there could be these people that
just,
you know,
harassed you based on your white male
privilege and you know,
oh you're conservative,
therefore you're evil and that's not
being a jerk.
But then,
you know,
questioning some of their viewpoints and
the narrative at Google that it's being
a jerk.
So white people are open game
essentially.
Like if someone is questioning you about
something and you happen to be a white
person,
they got to get away with far more.
Yeah.
They try to invoke this a lot too in
these programs where you're encouraged
when you ask a question or something you
say as a white male,
this is what I feel.
Oh Jesus.
And that.
I just think that that's really specific
as well.
White male with a fat Dick and a large
pornography collection on a hard drive.
That's how feel like
what?
No,
I think even mentioning pornography
would be some sort of microaggression
and that's a major aggression,
right?
Sexual harassment.
Yeah.
You were a.
They cited that you promoted harmful
gender stereotypes.
Right.
So I had to go over it again.
I'm like,
okay,
let's read this fucking thing one more
time.
Like I don't.
I don't think you've promoted any
stereotypes.
You were talking with citations about
science and that's,
that's where this whole thing really
confused the shit out of me.
What have you had many people like what
is the,
the,
has there been like a 50 slash 50 sort
of reaction,
like 50 percent of the people were like
me kind of confused about this and,
and then 50 percent of the people were
just knee jerk calling you some sort of
a sec.
A sexist or a Nazi.
Yeah.
So at Google they had an internal poll
with about 800 people and about 40
percent of people agreed.
And 40 percent.
Yeah.
Fifty percent disagree with 10 percent
were neutral.
Yeah.
Cowards.
And even the 50 percent,
probably a good percentage of them are
just being pussies.
It just doesn't.
It doesn't seem like if you're looking
at it really objectively,
you could look that they obviously want
a result and that result is the maximum
amount of diversity.
And I feel like if that's your result,
if that's what you're looking for,
shouldn't the result be let's not
discriminate,
just be open and just try to get the
best people.
Like wouldn't that be the best way to do
it?
And then if we run into problems like,
you know,
we've tried to do this best people
thing,
but all we have as Asians,
so,
uh,
yeah.
So even suggesting that we should go to
selling meritocracy thing.
That's a microaggression.
Meritocracy is a microaggression.
Yeah.
So what's the argument for that?
Like why is meritocracy a
microaggression?
Because it will make some people feel
unwelcome because they have to perform.
I really,
it's basically just anything against the
last ideology is a microaggression in
some ways.
So anything that could make anyone feel
offended,
particularly people in certain groups.
Man,
that's an liberal for a long time.
And I've never seen it this bad before.
You don't know what happened when it
happened.
So slippery it seems like within the
last 10 years,
right?
Yeah.
I think the Internet has celebrated a
lot of this where there can be these
online mobs that enforced these social
rules,
but I,
I think at least now some people can see
it for what it is.
Well,
I think
what you're seeing is that there's a
fear of retribution and that's one of
the reasons why people are towing the
line is that they're worried about
these,
like hyper aggressive people that are
coming out against people that don't toe
the line there,
you know,
like you're saying shaming you and that
that is,
that's a disturbing aspect of human
nature that I don't think she'd ever be
reinforced.
And,
and,
and I think it's hard to call those
things out individually because of
collectively as a group,
if this group of diversity minded folks
left wing minded social justice warrior
types are attacking you,
you feel very isolated and there's not a
lot of support,
you know?
And so most people just acquiesced they
just back off,
they just give in,
they toe the line,
they alter their thoughts or they keep
it to themselves.
Yeah.
And I mean I think shaming does have its
benefits it and when we were in small
groups,
you know,
if someone stole something or was mean,
Dan actually shaming them as good.
But you're talking about tribal groups
in the past.
Yeah.
But now that anyone across the world can
just randomly shame you and attack you,
that does not really what our brain was
meant for and just,
you know,
even me seeing just random messages
telling me that I'm some horrible person
that,
you know,
that hurts me even though I have gotten
a lot of actual private messages saying,
yeah,
we support you.
You're not alone,
but I have to keep my mouth shut.
I don't want to get fired from Yahoo.
Right.
I've met with so many people and they're
like.
And of course,
you know,
don't tell anyone that you.
That's so weird.
Now you obviously we're not a public
person,
right?
You were a guy just was working.
What is your job at Google?
A software engineer.
I was working on the indexing and
serving of a search.
So to go from that,
which is,
I'm like you,
you describe yourself as an introvert,
right?
And to go from that to this massive
exposure and to be the essentially the
lightning rod for a real hot topic.
I mean this is one of the most hot
button topics you can get.
Men versus women in tech are men and
women in tech,
women,
diversity,
white people,
black people,
racism.
Nazis who you're,
you're at the tip of the spear buddy.
Yeah,
and I'm really afraid that I'm actually
just polarizing issue even more and
separating people and because you know,
it's really shown that there are the
stereotypes are real and some ways that
there are some really extreme people on
the left and really extreme people in
the right maybe and you know,
we really need to bridge it and say,
okay,
let's actually have a discussion,
let's talk about what's actually
happening and nothing is really off the
table in this discussion,
but that's not happening.
And Google itself,
from what I've heard,
they've just been doubling down on the
diversity stuff and they haven't
addressed any of the political
discrimination.
Wow.
Well I think you're right and I think
that's.
That has to be your motivation for
writing that thing.
I mean,
that was a very well thought out memo
and I don't think someone who wanted to
separate people would have written that
the way it seemed to me as an outsider
with no dog in the fight.
I was looking.
I was like,
Oh,
this guy is probably like frustrated at
what he sees,
these sort of social justice warrior
tactics and these aren't logical and
that this is not rational,
and like maybe my breakdown of this
situation scientifically evolutionary
psychology studies and all these
different random factors that may have
contributed to women choosing these
careers.
Maybe this will help ease off.
Maybe people aren't aware of this
information.
Yeah.
I definitely have a bias where I thought
we could just sit down and discuss it
rationally.
That's all I ever wanted was sit down
and discuss it with them.
Yeah.
But I really underestimated the sort of
group based emotions that were behind
this and that's scary.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they're fucking.
One of the things that was important
about Charlotte,
I think Charlottesville rather,
is that we got to see real Nazis,
right?
Like,
hey man,
they're real.
It's not the fucking guy,
right in the Google memo,
it's this asshole with a swastika on his
chest is carry a Tiki torch walking down
the street with a gun in his pocket.
You know,
ranting about the Jews and black people.
That's a real Nazi and that is what you
were saying.
There's extreme people on the right and
there's extreme people on the left and
they they.
They don't understand that they are way
more similar than they like to believe.
If you believe that all white people are
racist,
if you believe that is an MPO is
impossible for you to be a white person
and not have some implicit bias and
racism and that it's impossible to be
racist against white people because
racism is about using power and
influence and minorities do not have
power and influence,
so they can be prejudice,
but they cannot be racist.
Well,
you're just as bad as the fucking person
with the Tiki torch.
You don't think you are.
I know you don't think you are,
but you want because you're just as
ridiculous.
You're so off of what is real.
You're so off.
You know the idea that all black people
responsible for the woes of society and
that none of it has to do with the fact
that were captured hundreds of years ago
and brought over here as slaves and that
there there are lesser as human beings.
That's a disgusting,
ridiculous proposition and the people
that think that way are fools,
right?
And that rightly so,
most people in the center look at those
as fools.
I look at the people that think that you
can't be racist against white people as
just as foolish.
You dumb fucks are fueling these
assholes like with this dumb way of
looking at things and pushing these
ridiculous ideas that all white people
are racist.
You're supposed to feel bad because
you're white.
I didn't do anything.
Didn't do anything,
didn't ask to be born white,
didn't ask to be born male.
Okay?
Like you can't get mad at people for who
they are.
You should.
We should be having an open discussion
about what is wrong,
like what's wrong?
Like how,
what,
what is going wrong?
Why is this happening?
Why are these negative things happening?
Not why don't we have more women or why
don't we have more Indian men are.
Why don't we.
I mean,
that's,
that's fucking ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And I didn't.
The two sides are just scapegoating,
so it is very similar and not taking any
personal responsibility.
At least,
you know,
what Jordan Peterson would say is just,
fix yourself before trying to fix the
ills of the world.
Well,
I mean I think there's also an issue
here is that I don't,
I've got to be very careful with my
words,
but I feel like this is a game and I
don't mean it's a game.
Like there's not,
it's not a real issue.
This app,
it's absolutely a real issue,
but I think people play for points and I
think that there's a real issue when
people do things for Social Brownie
points,
right?
Like Google saying that you were fired
for promoting unfair gender stereotypes
or dangerous or what was the word that
they use?
Harmful,
harmful,
harmful gender stereotypes.
That is a fucking play.
That's a play for points.
One hundred percent.
Okay.
Where are the fucking harmful gender
stereotypes?
Where are they promoted?
You tell me how.
If you don't tell me how I want a
fucking apology because you're lying.
You're lying because you want all those
people on the left.
It calmed down.
Well,
we fired him.
I fired him a month after you.
You knew he wrote that Shit.
Are you guys crazy?
Did you go over the science before you
fire them or.
No.
Like what did you,
what did you do?
Like where's the,
where's the harmful gender stereotypes
you guys talked about?
Yeah,
and I,
it sucks too because you really need to
address some of these things if you want
to address the gender gap.
And yeah,
that was what page of my thing was all
about was oh,
you know,
if women are more cooperative and they
approach the workplace differently than
maybe we can change our workplace to be
more approachable.
But if they're not willing to
acknowledge any of these differences
then you know,
they won't do anything.
So it's really annoying.
Well,
any interpersonal relationships with
random people can be messy.
You know,
you get a group of 30 people together,
you force them to work in a building and
it's going to be messy to where people
are messy.
We're weird,
you know,
and if you have more of one group than
another,
that groves is going to fail.
It alienated.
So if you have 80 percent men,
20 percent women,
they're going to feel alienated.
There's no way around it.
But the right way of approaching it is
not to distort the facts,
especially when you're thought of as
being.
I mean Google is essentially a pillar of
information.
I mean they're one of the most important
like hey man,
google it.
I mean that is the thing that people say
they're one of the most important
aspects of our society today.
Having the ability to instant nobody
says go bing that nobody gives a shit
about being right.
I mean as a joke,
but Google is hugely important.
So if you are essentially in charge of
the distribution,
have more knowledge than arguably
anything else on earth.
Maybe that's a big statement,
but I think.
I think you might be able to.
You might be able to actually say that
and be empty.
Pretty honest.
I think Google is responsible for
distributing more information than any
group on earth.
That's a giant responsibility.
That responsibility.
You cannot say that someone is promoting
harmful gender stereotypes when they're
absolutely not,
because I'm going over this fucking
thing.
I'm pulling pages out.
I'm like,
where's the harmful gender stereotypes
other than the word neuroticism.
I just don't.
If you got fired for the word
neuroticism,
well why is that word in all of these
evolutionary psychology texts?
Like what?
What's going on?
Yeah,
and if you just google personality
differences between men and women or
something,
then that'll be the first five results.
So it's.
Yeah,
and obviously these are just some of
them.
I mean there's a broad.
Again,
there's a broad spectrum of human beings
and both genders,
right?
Who are you suing them?
Yeah,
exploring all legal remedies.
That's.
Have they contacted you and go,
listen,
James will have to be so crazy.
James relaxed.
Let's go to dinner.
Let's have some falafel.
I am surprised that they never know when
they fired me had me try to sign
something to say,
Oh yeah,
you know,
just here's some nondisclosure agreement
or something and then just pay you off.
Yeah.
But that was a big fuck up on their
part.
It seems like it.
Well,
I think they feel like they're
completely.
I feel like the game again is like super
clear.
Like oh no,
we just,
we sunk a three pointer in.
It's no problem.
Like this is pretty.
This is pretty straightforward.
One of the net dude,
we don't have to do shit.
You have to pay him because he lost the
point,
you know,
and I think maybe they underestimated
how much negative press there would be
about this because a lot of the initial
stuff was all negative because it was
coming out of the people that were
tweeting about it and then they saw
that,
oh yeah,
the,
it's really not this one sided and you
know,
a lot of the things that may happen in a
case as you know,
there's a lot of discovery into what the
internals of Google are happening.
I don't think they want that to happen
because you will actually see that,
Oh yes,
maybe there was this illegal
discrimination happening.
Now what is illegal about the
discrimination that they're employing?
So I didn't and I'm not a lawyer,
so I can't say,
but at least according to our own
policies we said,
you know,
it's illegal to use someone's protected
status,
so their sex or gender or sex or race
and employment,
critical situations like,
you know,
when they're getting hired,
when they're trying to be matched to a
manager or to a team and when we're
choosing who to promote and.
But it,
it is happening in a lot of these
places.
Protected status.
Yeah.
That's how they refer to it internally.
Or is that like a common phrase?
I think that's a common phrase.
Well protected step.
What's protected about like,
yeah,
you're not supposed to be able to
discriminate on based on someone's age
or you know,
I mean it's mostly,
it was originally like,
oh yeah,
you shouldn't be discriminated against
black people,
but obviously,
I mean it should apply to everyone.
Right?
So by doing that,
they violated their own rules.
Right.
But they don't think about it that way
because they're promoting diversity by
doing that.
Yet it's kind of weird how they cited
some of the same parts of the code of
conduct where.
Oh yes,
every employee should do their utmost of
reducing bias and harassment and illegal
discrimination.
When really my document was about
eliminating the bias against
conservatives and the harassment against
them and the legal discrimination that
we're doing in multiple parts of our
pipeline.
There's no room for conservatives today
or.
I mean I'm.
Are you conservative?
Do you feel like you can tell I'm pretty
much just libertarian,
but that's thought of as conservative
because it's convenient.
You just immediately pushed off.
Yeah.
That right wing,
angry white male group.
Everyone that's in the center or right
of that is alright.
Alright.
Yeah,
it's pretty.
You favor of smaller government,
less intrusion.
Yeah.
I'm not super libertarian.
Like I obviously believe that there's
places where the government should be,
but just my,
my like internal leaning or in
philosophy is more like the.
Yeah,
I think socially I lean more left like
socially,
like in terms of like welfare and things
along those lines and you know,
obviously this protected status is
driving me crazy.
This,
this thing that trump's doing with um,
uh,
children that were born in this country
are born in other countries and then
brought over here as children and then
they're talking about deporting them.
That drives me fucking crazy.
The hard right version of that is
despicable.
This,
these people that I see online with,
why didn't they apply for citizenship?
Oh,
who knows?
Maybe because they're fucking 13,
you know,
like will you out there applying for
citizenship if you were 13?
No,
I mean when you're 13 years old you're
playing games and hanging out with your
friends and then you find out you were
born in Guatemala and you're like,
what?
Like you have to go back to Guatemala.
What?
Yeah,
it's crazy sex.
I lean way left when it comes to those
kinds of things.
Gay Rights and things like,
um,
you know,
uh,
social programs for disenfranchised
people and disenfranchised communities.
I leaned way like if I want my tax
dollars to go to anything I wanted to go
to,
making people's lives easier,
whether it's socialized medicine or
whatever,
whatever we could do to make people have
an easier path to success and to not
have them so burdened down by their
environment and their circumstances.
That I think is like our responsibility
as human beings to try to,
I don't want to say even the playing
field because there's never going to be
an even playing field,
but to give people opportunity,
that's it.
Just give people an opportunity to do
well,
not have it so completely stacked
against them.
So in that sense,
I'm not very conservative in that way.
Like I'm not one of those pull yourself
up by your bootstraps that because
that's just,
that's so delusional.
Like some people are just fucked,
you know,
they,
they're born with a terrible hand and it
would be nice if more of us were
charitable in that regard.
You know?
And some people think that that charity
should be a personal issue and that we
should all just do it,
you know,
as part of our community and our
society.
Maybe that's a good argument.
And,
but maybe the argument is that our
government should be a part of our
community,
you know,
and that we should think about it that
way instead of thinking of it as,
as,
as this overlord that decides and
designates where our money should go,
that maybe we should have some more say
in it,
it should be some sort of a,
a more,
um,
you know,
just,
just a,
a more,
uh,
more kind approach.
So in that sense,
I leaned pretty far left,
but I'm also pretty pragmatic,
you know,
and I,
and I also know that if you give people
too much,
it's sort of that winning lottery ticket
thing or that you know,
that if you,
if you make things too easy for people,
they don't try hard.
It's just a natural part of human
nature.
So in that sense,
some conservative
and a lot of ways,
yeah,
you definitely need some sort of safety
net and to ensure that people can
actually achieve the American dream.
Well just be healthy,
make our live and bleeding more and more
towards the universal basic income than
anything.
I think universal basic income at a
certain point to elegant enough that you
can just eat and survive and then maybe
that would open up a lot more people to
pursuing dreams to going after things.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean there's arguments for and against
and I think it's debatable.
It will be interesting to see know
Finland I think was proposing to start
this because we don't really know what
will happen.
Right?
And maybe people will start doing their
hobbies and really find their passion.
Maybe they'll just sit at home and watch
TV and die.
Yeah,
I,
it's really.
These are the problems that we as a
society will have to overcome.
And you know,
of course these are just first world
problems,
but that's,
that will be what the world is like.
There was another country today.
I read about it on Google a,
another country today that's considering
universal basic income.
Fucking was it South Korea?
Oh really?
Um,
see if he could find it.
It's in Scotland.
Is that what it was?
Oh,
I think there's many,
many people that are.
I mean,
Elon Musk has been promoting this
lately.
Scotland will begin funding universal
basic income experiments.
Yeah,
Hawaii,
that's what it was.
Hawaii considers universal basic income
as robot scene,
stealing jobs.
Fucking robots running around the
streets.
Stealing jobs.
Yeah.
It's Hawaii
I think are,
is,
uh,
some real arguments to be made.
And I think,
um,
Elon musk who is of course a part of
this automated a car revolution and
he's,
uh,
he's creating these,
these trucks that they're gonna start
using to haul things and they're going
to be automated and it's going to remove
a lot of jobs and they're starting to
talk about universal basic income as you
know,
a real solution to that mean
it's entirely possible.
It's certainly an argument,
you know,
it's certainly worth discussing yet,
something like that.
And hopefully the incentives will be
better than some of the current welfare
systems where you know,
you're not incentivized to get off of
it.
Yeah.
If you start working then you'll lose
all of it while universal basic income
can be made such that you start working
and then you'll lose a little bit.
But it's never an actual incentive to
not work.
Yes.
Right.
It's not an incentive to not work,
but it's an,
it gives you food and shelter.
Right.
So then you could go pursue a dream,
which I think it would be wonderful.
I mean,
look,
if there's anything that our tax dollars
should be going towards,
it's creating less losers,
less people who feel disenfranchised by
the system.
You
know,
if you're,
if you can pay x amount of tax dollars
but live in an exponentially more safe
and friendly and happy environment.
I think most people would be leaning
towards that.
I think it would
because.
Yeah,
I mean,
and we'll see this.
We see us too.
And um,
people that start companies where as a
huge risk to start a company,
most people fail.
And most entrepreneurs in silicon valley
are men who are much more willing to
take risks,
but if we do have some sort of strong
safety net then it won't be so bad if
you fail.
And maybe that'll help address some of
the gender gap too.
That's interesting.
You know,
it's,
we want women to succeed in these
positions so badly that like a woman ceo
can become like a superstar.
Like that lady from that blood testing
company that turned out to be bullshit.
Was that Thanos?
Is that the name of it?
There are.
No,
sir.
That was a fascinating case.
This woman essentially was role playing
as a female steve jobs with a bullshit
product that didn't really do what it
was advertised to do and her company was
valued at something like 30 something
billion dollars and she was thought to
be the richest self made woman in the
world.
And then almost overnight she's worth
nothing because they found out it
doesn't work.
And the company sort of fell apart.
There it is.
How Elizabeth Holmes House of cards game
came tumbling town.
It is a fascinating story because this
woman look at her,
they're dressed the part put on a
fucking black turtleneck.
I mean,
she dressed like Steve Jobs.
I remember,
um,
she gave this speech once at some
woman's for women's success group for
something or another.
And uh,
she got up there and in this like
unprepared rambling,
stupid speech and I was like,
how is this woman this super genius?
Well,
it turns out she wasn't,
you know,
she dropped out of college at Nineteen
and,
and created this company.
She started this when she was in
college,
you know,
and she,
she basically just fit what people were
looking for,
you know,
and,
and bullshitted away to billions almost,
you know,
to kind of crazy.
Yeah.
A lot of people are very willing to see
that whatever narrative they want.
Yeah.
And I,
and we see this all the time in the
media too,
where they just fit the data however
they want.
Right.
Which is why they wanted to call you a
misogynist.
Yeah.
When I,
when I first read that,
I was like,
wow.
Like uh,
this is a,
this is a hot take by this lady who.
Sure.
The article,
I think she wrote one of them was a let
me lady explain what's going on with
women in tech.
Did you read that one?
I saw.
I don't remember.
There's so many.
Yeah,
there's a lot of it,
dude.
There's a lot of it.
So where are you right now?
I mean,
do
you,
you obviously,
did they give you some sort of a,
a pension or something like that?
They didn't have any money.
They just fire you
now.
I,
yeah,
I've been cheap throughout the years
though.
So he saved up some cash.
That's good.
Still trying to figure out what's next.
Have you got any job offers?
I've gotten random job offers from
people but I haven't.
Alright.
It's hard to tell how serious they are.
If you thought about writing a book yet.
I have not seen much of a writer.
So you wrote that memo pretty well?
Yeah,
I mean I'm famous for what I wrote,
but I'm not,
it's,
you know,
if I had been studying how to write and
stuff my entire life,
I wouldn't have been an engineer,
but we did a great job with it though.
Yeah,
I mean it was very thorough.
I like to think so.
I,
it,
it addressed a lot of things and it's
unfortunate that there was that one part
that is getting so much attention when
really it pointed out a lot of problems
in our culture and a lot of suggestions
for how to fix things and it seems like
none of that is really gaining traction.
Yeah,
no,
well it least,
it started the conversation,
right?
Not at least for you because you got
fired.
I mean in some ways though,
it has made it even more dangerous to
bring these up.
At least,
you know,
it's sort of empowered some people to at
least understand some of the issues and
hopefully these things will get brought
up.
But right now it's sort of a toxic,
a tough topic to bring up at Google at
least.
Do you think that it's toxic in,
in the short term,
but in the long term it'll inspire a
more reasoned,
balanced conversation once the dust has
settled,
hopefully.
And you know,
that's sort of one of the hopes with the
lawsuit is to show people that no,
Google can't just do this,
that there are limits to how much they
can silence things.
Yeah.
And you shouldn't be afraid to point out
issues in the workplace.
Right.
And you just said with the lawsuit like
it's absolutely happening.
Yeah,
I believe we filed a claim with the nlrb
which is the national labor relations
board.
Uh,
and so they usually work with unions and
you know,
it's often employers that try to break
up unions and fire people for joining
unions.
And that's illegal and you know,
a lot of this,
what I was doing was a conservative
effort between multiple people that,
you know,
trying to improve the workplace and
actually know whistle blow on some of
the illegal practices.
Did you save emails where people were
shaming people for being white or
shaming people for having implicit bias
because there were white or harassing
people for
yet a lot of people have been doing
this,
like there's some efforts within google
to at least document some of this
because while they may not be the
majority,
they,
they're sort of a silent,
a coalition within Google that's sort of
upset about a lot of this.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So there are some conservative people
that work at Google.
Yeah,
I mean there's definitely more than
zero,
more than zero.
Um,
is it like 20 percent,
like the amount that are represented,
like women that are representing the
company.
So I,
it,
it may be that or even lower,
I think there's a lot of libertarians.
So that would be the main counter to the
extreme left.
But,
and then like,
so like what the main retributions
against people are the social
conservatives and they feel completely
alienated.
So it's really unfortunate for them.
But I,
yeah,
there's at least hundreds of them
now.
When you say like social conservatives,
like what,
what do you,
how do you classify that?
Like what would,
I mean I guess people that believe in
traditional values and
homophobes say it.
So I think this is
a lot of what's happening too on where
people just assume,
okay,
because you believe say in traditional
values and you think that your marriage
is an important thing and you know,
I think that there is evidence that uh,
you know,
bringing out people in a two parent
household whether or not it's,
you know,
the same sex or different sex that is
important for children and there there's
a huge disparity and outcome of people
with only one parent versus two.
So there is something to be said about
marriage and having cultural norms that
support that,
but so you're just completely alienating
that side of the argument is really
negative and that's hurt our society in
general,
I think.
Yeah.
Well I think anytime you silence
discussion based on your own personal
ideas of what should and shouldn't be
debated,
I think becomes an issue.
I mean,
you can disagree with someone and that's
a very complicated issue when it comes
to whether or not to parents or,
or more beneficial to a child than one
because obviously there's a lot of
reasons why people break up,
you know,
you don't want to encourage people to be
in toxic relationships and then show the
child that,
you know,
this is a framework for a loving
relationship.
People that scream at each other and
whatever horrible shit they do to each
other,
that gets super complicated and very,
very personal.
Right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's definitely a touchy subject,
a very personal one.
Yeah.
So I,
I don't know how to address that,
but I think it's at least something that
we should be cognizant of.
Has Anybody said when you know,
these white people are being shamed in
this,
you know,
as anybody ever stepped up and say,
Hey,
this is racist.
They might've but never in a public
forum that I ever.
But publicly white people have been
criticized.
Right.
And you know,
there's all these negative stereotypes
of men and white people and you know,
those gender stereotypes are fine.
But,
and you know,
the whole idea that,
you know,
I'm only here because of my white male
privilege,
therefore I'm somehow worst programmer
than all the other non white non males.
Is that implied or is that stated?
I think it's implied that they get it
easier in life and in the interview
process and evaluations.
Yeah,
white and Asian males.
So how's it implied though?
Can you give me an example?
And they'll say explicitly that just
yes,
these,
these groups of people are
disadvantaged,
these are advantaged,
there's this privilege that they have
and we've seen it time and again through
all these evaluation processes that
they're better evaluated and these are
worse and yeah,
they like,
they often just see whatever data that
they want,
you know,
like the case before where they just
pulled out the female side without
seeing that,
oh the male side was pretty much the
same [inaudible] and it's crazy and
they,
you even see it in some of their
internal studies where,
you know,
they were trying to show how racist or
sexist Google was and how worse women
habits.
So they were looking at the code review
process where you know,
you can submit code to be reviewed and
then someone has to approve it before it
goes into the code base and they were
looking at,
okay,
if a woman's the author of it,
how many comments do they get on this
review and you know,
if they got more comments then that
would mean that their work is more
scrutinized.
But if they got fewer comments then they
were just ignored.
And so there's no way out of it,
you know,
any result which show that women are
being discriminated,
discriminated against somehow.
Wow.
Man,
I'm glad I don't work where you worked.
You happy to be free of that at all?
I missed the free food.
Good food there.
Yeah,
I liked the food a lot.
I had a friend who is a big executive
over there,
a woman by the way,
woman.
Oh Shit.
Um,
yeah,
she,
she enjoyed it but she said it was a
mess like in.
She didn't know how,
obviously have the same issues that you
had,
but she was like that.
The whole thing is just chaos yet.
Stupid shit going on over there.
She hated it.
There's definitely,
and I went in a little bit in this,
in the document to where if you have a
company that's to progressively run,
then it'll be sort of this,
you know,
everyone's equal and no hierarchy and
all chaos and are constantly changing
wild,
you know,
the opposite of a really conservative
company where there's a lot of hierarchy
decisions are made from the top with
which may not be,
you know,
very easy to change things.
So like iron.
Google is definitely more of the former
where there is a lot of chaos and
there's multiple teams working on the
same thing and it's just this is how we
have multiple products that end up doing
the same thing and we have to deprecate
some bright like we have.
That's very inefficient for different
chat apps.
Well Google is
as in the technology realm,
but they're not,
they don't have a lot of competition.
That's what's really interesting.
But then they do in certain ways,
right?
Like they do in the phone way.
Like they put out the Pixel,
which I bought,
which is kind of a fucked up phone.
Yeah.
It doesn't feel like the,
the microphone doesn't work all the
time.
Yeah.
Like could you have to let go to
speakerphone and then bring it back to
microphone?
Just a bunch of bugs.
So quite a few issues with it.
Then there's the android operating
system which a lot of people prefer.
So I think they're like pretty
competitive in that round.
But like um,
when it comes to like search engine,
so they don't really have competition.
That's where it gets real sneaky because
a lot of power in that search search
engine.
And then in Gmail.
What,
what?
Uh.
Well you know,
what competition they have in Gmail as a
fuck about hotmail.
I started using
Yahoo Mail because people were really
suspicious that google would eventually
read my email.
Oh Wow.
Do you really worry about that?
That they would spy on your email?
There were some weird things happening
to my phone,
so I had like one attached to it yet.
What?
Uh,
so my Corp,
so Corp,
my work phone and basically.
Okay.
And it started like rebooting and after
this whole controversy given android.
Yeah,
it's.
And this had never happened before and
it hasn't happened and didn't like all
these random apps started updating.
It was Kinda scary.
But.
So do you think they start spying on
you?
It's your way to find out.
I don't know if there's a way to find
out.
Fuck,
I'd put my phone aside and bring it to
light the top technologist and go,
listen,
we've got to go over this because
that'll be giant dude.
If you found they were spying on you,
is there anything in your contract that
allows them to spy on you?
Yeah,
there's some random things where they.
they can basically just spy on you
completely.
Yeah.
Like how,
so uh,
so all of your keystrokes or sort of
logged in at work or.
I'm the work computer.
Yeah.
Not necessarily your personal laptop or
anything.
Okay.
What about your phone yet?
So I don't know exactly what they do,
but the corporate phone,
my Google Dot com account attached to
it.
Okay.
But it wasn't your personal phone?
Yeah,
I bought it.
But then.
Oh,
so yeah,
they,
they reserved the right to like
completely new kit and what?
Yeah,
served right to,
to nuke your personal phone.
Now this corporate phone,
are you allowed to use it for like say
if you go on a date or you want to buy a
movie ticket or.
So you're allowed to use that.
Yeah,
so that's a weird marriage of two
worlds,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's,
some people would own two phones because
of that,
but you know,
I was,
I'm a cheap person again,
I don't want to have google pay for
extra stuff and I mean I can understand
why they would want that because
especially,
you know,
I was traveling to China for some of my
work and supposedly if they see that you
work for Google,
they'll just steal your laptop or your
phone or they won't even explicitly
steal it.
They'll go into your room and then
install some software on it and then
just put it there and then the Chinese
government will somehow get into
Google's networks.
Whoa.
So I mean they're rightfully paranoid
about somethings,
but sometimes it's you don't want to
give one entity too much power.
Yeah.
My friend who worked for Google was very
upset at this whole China thing because
essentially she was saying they have to
agree to censorship the Chinese
censorship and that the only alternative
is to let China steel all of what
Google's doing and make a fake google
because that's what they were doing
apparently.
Yeah.
To make sure that they didn't allow
that.
And then to do that they had to have
certain things like tenement square,
you couldn't search for that and it's
like a lot of weird shit that they would
have to sensor any dissented the
government and you know,
gets very slippery.
Right?
I mean like yeah,
you're anti diverse or you're pro
diversity,
but you're also,
you're supporting that like as a company
that's a giant issue.
Like to allow China to censor it
citizens.
I mean you're,
you're essentially promoting a
dictatorship in that regard.
Yeah.
It's sort of a lose lose.
I don't know what exactly they should do
and they just did it for business.
I think I just made a business choice
and so fucking scary choice to.
Yeah,
well I mean they.
They were in China and they supported
some of this stuff,
but then they eventually chose not to
because they backed out of it.
Is that recent?
That was a,
I don't know.
Before my time at Google at nationally,
so they decided to get out so they're
not involved with China anymore.
It's blocked by the firewall.
China block,
Google and all of Google services.
Don't they have some weird thing you can
get around that though,
but that's super illegal if you get
around that,
you get in really big trouble.
Yeah.
Although their official policy is that
there is no firewall,
so I don't know if they have any laws to
actually imagine that fucking building
people.
They figured out how to do that to them
yet,
although I think China is not the only
case where this is happening.
There's other countries where Google
also has the sensor.
Really?
Yeah,
like in the Middle East.
There's some company or some countries
that do that.
It gets really complicated.
Yeah.
I could imagine.
Look,
I don't envy them,
I don't,
and I don't envy any of the people that
work there and management that are sort
of responsible for putting out,
you know,
an infinite number of forest fires all
around them all the time.
Social Economic,
you know,
dealing with different cultures.
It's not,
it doesn't seem like it'd be an easy
gig.
Yeah.
And I,
one of the ways they have now too is you
know,
even though they have a large market
share for a search,
they see search as sort of a gateway to
the world and they don't necessarily
have a huge market share for that
because you know,
facebook and twitter are also ways to
get to the world's information and a lot
of facebook just,
it's just a walled garden where Google
can't really get into that.
So some people just.
And you know,
on your phone you spend most of your
time on facebook or something and not
necessarily just doing random google
searches,
you know?
Yeah.
I got off of that.
I don't really go on facebook for that
very reason.
It seems to be to be the biggest sucker
time that we have.
I just,
I feel like twitter to me is like,
it's limited by 140 characters.
It seems pretty straightforward.
I get links.
Good.
Interesting.
Stories get sent to me that for my needs
that's more,
it's more appealing.
And then instagram is very appealing
because I like images so you can look at
pictures and sometimes people write cool
captions and you find out about
interesting shit.
But facebook is like,
whew,
boy,
you're gonna lose a lot of time on that
motherfucker.
Oh,
so this is a random tangent.
But I knew so I worked on image search
and they also see that even though there
isn't a huge competitor for image
search,
there's instagram and pinterest which
are very similar things and you know,
we do our demographic research and we
really look into why people are using
these products and we see that the
majority of the users are women and you
know,
they actually know why that is.
It's that women prefer,
you know,
art and aesthetics over men and on
average.
Right.
And that's exactly what I had in the
document,
like we openly acknowledge this when
we're looking at the products because
otherwise you're not going to give these
random ads to people that you know,
if you know that they're a man and
you're not going to give them ads for
women products,
you know.
So ad science does discriminate and
stereotype people in some ways,
but it's okay now they're getting into
trying to de bias machine learning.
So if they do see any things that the
machine learning has learned these
statistical anomalies or just trends in
the data,
then they'll try to remove that.
Why that seems like it would be less
effective.
It's less effective,
but they see it as discrimination.
Social Justice.
Yeah.
It's
and mess.
What a mess.
Bang.
You need to step up your game.
Come on back.
Bring back that windows phone.
Come on.
Hotmail.
Microsoft had hotmail,
right?
Nobody uses hotmail.
Does that even real anymore?
They have hotmail I think so I saw,
I've been getting a lot of emails from,
you know,
pretty paranoid people and some of them
are from hot now.
So.
Oh yeah.
How about AOL?
Yeah.
Well dot comment on.
Well,
what the fuck all is real.
Who the hell is aol?
Where are you right now?
Like where we're,
where are you?
What do you do with your time?
The I read books,
uh,
respond to media requires a lot of them.
Yeah.
I still get a lot and you know,
thankfully now some of them are more of
the long form,
which ilr I like a lot more than just
the five minute TV thing.
I wanted to give you as much time as he
could to just talk about this and
especially after I heard you on Ben
Shapiro,
Cheryl show,
I'm like this getting the shaft.
You're very reasonable person.
You're not a misogynist at all as far as
I can tell he,
you don't seem like a sexist.
You don't seem cruel.
You're not like the type of person.
I think we'd go out of their way to
promote some sort of a quote unquote
harmful stereotype gender stereotype.
It just seems so weird.
Especially like I personally am just
very conscious about a lot of these
gender stereotypes and you know,
I use the word day whenever the,
uh,
when I read the gender of someone is
unknown or just unimportant [inaudible]
and like I try to avoid using guys
instead of just like you all or
something.
Yeah.
I say folks,
I try to say folks now because I used to
say guys lot,
you know,
I try to use the term folks yet for that
very reason.
Yeah.
And you know,
if I get married,
I,
I would actually try to merge our last
name somehow.
Don't do that dude.
Not,
not like the highest band,
not the hyphen,
but just like create a new name,
create a new name.
That would be the coolest if,
if you can do it.
Well,
you know,
the former mayor of Los Angeles did
that.
Really?
Yeah.
His name is Tony Volare and his wife had
this ethnic name and so they changed it
and put it together and he came to Villa
Arago Lavilla or Villaraigosa.
I think that's what his name was,
but it made him seem like he was Mexican
and so that's why you went with it and
he kept it even after they got divorced.
Yeah,
it's super like Adam Kroll is shits on
them for it.
I didn't even know about it until he
explained it to me.
I went what?
Like it's a fake name because I mean I
just,
I,
I don't.
I wouldn't want my wife to take my last
name and lose theirs.
I refuse to let my wife use her own
name.
You can?
Yeah.
Villa or young.
Go saw Villaraigosa for Laura goes.
You could make a really cool last name.
Yeah,
that's what he did.
I mean,
he was Volare Antonio Ramon Volare
junior and his wife was a Ria.
Goza.
That's pretty cool.
Then they split up,
but he kept that name.
Kept that fucking ethnic name.
As long as you don't Google search at
when you do you go,
Hey,
what?
What's your dad's name,
Bro?
Yeah.
I mean there are people that have stage
names are okay.
Yeah.
I'm Nikki Glaser at a very funny joke
about that and she stand up.
Comedian,
she had a funny joke about,
um,
your old name,
you know,
and then like when a woman gets married
and then like her all,
her name is when her son and gets locked
out of his bank account and needs to
know mom was your old day.
Like in terms of like how to access his
account with a password.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
it'd be nice if everybody just kept
their own fucking name.
But then once you do to the kids,
that's yes.
To kill the kid,
to pick your favorite parent.
Yeah.
Who's your favorite parent?
Have a meritocracy inside your own
family now you can't do that,
right?
Yeah.
And then if you have it,
so the first child is this second child,
is that,
then it just gets too confusing.
And then what if you changed your name
and then you break up,
you go back to your old name.
It depends on how cool it is a bit out
of and then you keep it.
It's good.
It keeps you in great shape with the
ethnic market markets maybe.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Tricky.
I don't know.
Marriage in itself is very weird.
It's some sort of strange legal contract
with the state that involves
relationships,
which is just so bizarre,
which is why 50 percent of them fall
apart,
you know,
and that's.
Chris Rock had a great joke about that.
That's the coward's that stay like how
many,
how many of the people stay 50 percent
left.
Like how many people are fucking
miserable and they're still involved in
that contract and it's 50 percent that
fail.
It's a good argument,
you know?
Yeah.
It is.
It the 50 percent of the initial ones
get a breaking up or just 50 percent of
all marriages.
So like there are some that get married
10 times and they get counted in that 50
percent.
Yes.
Because initial marriages,
like if you get a union.
I do,
I do.
How many of those work?
Fifty percent stay unionized?
Oh Man.
Of the first one.
That's pretty bad.
It's not good.
Yeah,
it's not good.
I'm,
I'm happily married and I tell people
don't do it.
I'm worried that it's not worth it,
it's a fucking ridiculous proposition.
And if you're,
um,
whether you're male or female,
that makes a lot of money and the spouse
doesn't,
then you run into this very weird
situation,
you know,
it's,
it's scary.
[inaudible] and you know,
potential of losing custody of kids.
Yes.
Yeah.
It gets real weird,
but it makes sense with children because
you know,
like look,
creating life is way more of a
commitment than divorce and marriage
because you could,
you could easily get divorced.
People do it every day,
but creating life is like,
that's a significant responsibility.
I mean it's gigantic.
You could get along with someone else.
I mean you could get divorced and go
through all the turmoil and all the
stress and then find a new person and
maybe they'll be.
Maybe it'll be better.
Maybe marry that person and to work out.
Well maybe you learned from your first
relationship,
but I think the commitment of raising a
human being is way more of a,
like a serious long term responsibility.
So if you could do that,
like you can stay married,
if it work it out,
as long as the person's reasonable get a
reasonable person would.
Do you know anyone that's getting an
arranged marriage or has arranged
marriage?
No,
I don't because those actually it was a
weird day.
Stay together more than not 50 percent.
Really?
Yeah.
So like,
like,
uh,
like rich parents get together with
another rich family and they bring over
the daughter and we kind of not
necessarily just rich.
I think that happens a lot and more
traditional countries like India,
it's still happens.
What does that,
the divorce is over,
but the myth lives on.
That's a chick or wrote that.
I just thought propaganda.
That's fake news.
Get that shit off the screen.
What does it say?
I just saw another article in psychology
today.
It said it's down to about 25 or 75
percent survive.
Wow.
Yeah.
One in four and a divorce.
But if you get married a second or third
time,
the rates go way up.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
It says it's like a myth,
quote unquote myth from the seventies
and eighties.
But there also isn't the amount of time
if you got married in the last 10 years
to say you're going to get divorced in
20 more years,
I would like to know what the actual
hard data with the United States of
America.
Because culturally it gets weird when
you look across the different countries.
But what about the United States of
America?
What are the percentage of people who
get married to wind up getting divorced?
Let's find that out.
What do you say it is?
Oh,
across the world?
No,
no,
no.
Just United States.
The United States.
I would think I'm sort of trusting that
random.
You think it's about 25 percent?
Get divorced.
Divorce rate in the US drops to nearly
40 year low.
Wow.
Look at this represents
a jump from 31 point nine and 2014 and
is the highest number.
Okay.
30 two point two.
Marriage rates the other hand have
increased.
There's 32 point two marriages for every
thousand unmarried,
but what is the divorce rate?
16 point nine for a thousand married
women.
Fifteen year old.
What is the fucking percentage?
You fucking 23.
They throw around too many 50 percent
chance.
Okay.
Typical marriage is still have a 50
percent chance of lasting.
That's all I said.
So same goddamn number.
Researchers have found that typical
marriage is still have about a 50
percent chance of lasting.
That's very fucking.
This is still just colored including the
second and third marriages and beyond.
Well,
marriage is marriage.
I mean if you have a second,
marriage means you failed.
It means you got divorced.
Yeah.
But if.
Go back to that Jamie please.
It says researchers have found that
typical marriages still have a 50
percent chance of lasting.
That means you have a 50 percent chance
of not lasting,
but that's just assuming you look at
every single marriage,
but if you look at the first marriage,
then maybe you have a 70 percent chance
of never getting a divorce and then.
But if you do get it,
so you like factored in when people are
in like the second,
third and fourth,
Maryland.
Those Elizabeth Taylor type folks.
I was like nine or 10 marriages,
so it might have reduced because people
are just getting married later,
so they're choosing rather than just,
Oh,
I got pregnant when I was young or I
didn't have anything else to do,
so I got married.
We'll get that.
Hawaii had the lowest because it's
fucking awesome.
Then maybe if you live somewhere
awesome,
they have universal basic income.
Great.
Why?
They're great marriages.
What did you put up,
Jamie?
What do you highlighted?
Uh,
just other things that they're saying
factor and like cohabitating has become
less stigmatized so they're not living
together but not getting married as
another thing.
Oh,
okay.
People don't look to shore up and
unstable relationship.
Marriage rates have been declining for
years,
so less people get married,
but the percentage is still.
You also don't have to get married when
you have a kid right now.
That's right.
Right,
right.
Brushing and do it.
Right.
Right,
right.
It's less stigmatized.
[inaudible].
Yeah.
I mean,
imagine if that was a friendship thing.
Okay man,
we be best friends or what?
Fucking go to court dude,
and do this.
I mean it's just this weird.
I mean,
it really is,
it does,
it makes sense for some people.
They like it.
People like rituals,
you know,
feels good to know,
like say it and do it and make it real
and jump over the broom like they didn't
roots.
I think one interesting thing that I was
looking into a little bit was the rates
of divorce for homosexual marriages
because that,
that's also sort of interesting.
So one thing about heterosexual is
women and initiate the divorce in 70
percent of cases.
Of course they do,
which is,
you know,
I wouldn't have necessarily predicted
that Adeline.
So I think when we get pissed more like
that on you tell you.
Yeah,
I guess,
but relationships that you've been in,
have women been pissed off at you more
than you've been pissed off at them or
the opposite?
Definitely.
They get mad at me.
Says you're a God damn.
Promoting harmful gender stereotypes.
I sign up.
I generally just don't get that angry.
So I think that's part of it,
but that's probably where they get mad
at you.
You don't even fucking care.
And so like,
not to push on the one thing that sort
of hurt me,
but the neuroticism trait is actually
has been linked to on stable marriages.
Women having more of that has been part
of the explanation for why.
And so you see in lesbian couples,
they also have a higher rate of divorce
then the gay couple,
the gay men.
That's interesting.
So like part of it is women want to
settle down much faster so they'll move
in within like a month.
And then,
which obviously is,
you're too soon to know whether or not
that's a longterm chip.
Well,
especially if neither one of you are
flexible and you know,
sort of adapt to each other's needs and
desires.
So,
uh,
I interrupted you though.
What is the percentage of gay men who,
how often are they get divorced,
I don't know the exact numbers,
but it's lower than the lesbian one and
because we only had the last few years
or so of gay marriage.
So we don't know the actual long term
rates,
but it's certainly interesting because,
you know,
it's a world that I don't know much
about.
Brian has,
um,
how have you come through all this,
like do you feel damaged by this at all?
Do you feel like your name is this
marched a definitely,
you know,
I,
I just went to a party with my friends
and some of them were much closer to and
I had already talked to about this some
I hadn't and you know,
you never know how they felt about it.
So some,
it seemed like they,
you know,
I could tell that they were like,
oh yeah man,
hey,
what's up bus bro.
Keep it secret handshake.
But others were maybe a little averse to
me.
So that may happen in the future,
but prejudices that they have going into
the conversation.
Yeah.
And Oh,
I didn't know that you are a sexist.
What have you gotten that if he hadn't
been people like outright insulting you.
There was one person that was on just on
the roads,
just f you.
Really?
Yeah,
in the road.
Where was this in mountain view?
So you're driving your car?
I just got out of my car and they just
yelled at were female.
It was a guy.
And what he say just after you just fuck
you for what?
For how do you know that?
That's why he said that.
Uh,
well yeah.
I mean I've never really been yelled at
except by like crazy people on the
street with this guy look like just
normal nerd guy.
Did he have his girlfriend with him
trying to press her?
Maybe that con,
that Shit.
I want to smack him,
God.
But I,
most of the support or at least like
personal interactions have been in
support of me.
So there've been random people like,
oh,
are you James Tomorrow?
It's like,
yeah.
Wow.
So one guy with a girl yelled out,
fuck you.
And he looked like a nerd.
She'll,
she'll dump him.
Don't worry about it,
buddy.
It'll all come around.
I had a friend that was like that.
He was super fucking male feminist.
And then eventually his,
uh,
his spouse went nutty on them and crazy.
And then all of her friends went nutty
on him.
And now he's like,
he man,
woman haters club.
He went the other way.
Oh really?
Not totally,
but he's like,
what the fuck man?
I'm like,
yeah,
you can't just rely on a gender to be
cool to rely on individual human beings
and their personalities and their
actions and their character.
I can't believe we have to actually go
over this,
but no,
like all in all,
men aren't great.
All in all.
Women aren't great.
You find unique people that are cool in
all sorts of groups.
Yeah.
And you know,
once you start aligning yourself with
one of these groups and you know,
if you ever go against any of their
principals and you know,
they're constantly changing and getting
more extreme,
then you'll eventually get ostracized
and yeah,
that's what happened.
That that's a big issue with the left.
Sure.
You know,
left eats itself,
but I don't think that's as much of an
issue with the conservative.
Right?
Rational conservatives not like racists
and like full right wing nuts.
But you know,
I think
what people just want,
they,
they want harmony.
I think overall they want to succeed and
they want harmony,
which sometimes are mutually exclusive.
Yeah.
And you know,
a lot of people just don't acknowledge
that,
you know,
most people are normal and they're just,
yeah,
want to live their life and you know,
even though they might have voted for
trump for something,
they're not some evil person,
they're not the KKK,
which I've met a lot of people in
Silicon valley that basically equate
voting for trump and being in the KKK.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's harmful.
That's really splitting groups.
And you know,
if you're going to build products that
are for the entire world,
then you really need to understand other
people especially,
you know,
a lot of the world is actually more
conservative than.
I mean Europe may be more liberal than
the US in some ways,
but a lot of Asia and Africa and South
America is more conservative than we
are.
So we need to at least understand what's
happening and what their worldview is.
Yeah.
The idea that everyone who voted for
trump is a
in the KKK so crazy,
but it's convenient to demonize the
other.
We would love to do that.
We'd love to look at groups and just
block ourselves off.
And this is us and we're on the right
and these people on the other side
there,
they're incorrect and it's a real normal
common tendency that human beings have
that we should be very,
very aware of,
but we're not,
you know,
we have these convenient blinders that
we put on whenever we're engaging in a
sort of ideological discussions where
our belief systems might be challenged
where we dig our heels in and like,
this is it.
I think you see a lot of that with the
left,
with this whole.
Like you can not be progressive enough.
Like it's like they're getting wackier
and whack here with it.
It's just really weird.
Yeah.
No,
no concept of,
you know,
okay,
I am an ally with you on this thing,
even though we may disagree on this
other subject.
And that's just completely impossible in
their head.
Yeah.
Well I don't think there's enough real
discussions going on in this world too.
I think people are a lot of times
following these predetermined patterns
of behavior.
They think they're expected to follow as
a progressive or as a conservative and
then they just go with it.
And then when they do engage with
someone who has a different opinion,
then it becomes a in quotes game again,
it's trying to win rather than trying to
understand like what this person sees
and what they think.
And what is your philosophy like how
were you approaching this?
And trying to be like really open minded
about it.
You know,
like I see this even in myself when I'm
talking to someone and you know,
maybe there are feminists are like
extreme in some way and like I'll
discuss them and I'll immediately just
stereotype them as someone that's even
more extreme and I'll read into their
words of Oh you said that that means
that you mean this.
And even though you know,
maybe it's important to at least show
what the extreme outcome would be and
therefore we can't just take this on
principle.
But you know,
everyone does it and it's really hard to
not do it.
It is hard to not do it.
It's one of the reasons why I think like
long form form conversations are so
important.
And how often do you ever sit down like
this with someone and talk for a couple
hours with just you and the person
talking,
not looking at your phone,
not checking the TV?
Not,
no,
no.
We were very rarely do this.
I think this is one of the only ways we
could really work out ideas,
especially when you're talking to
someone that might have a different
opinion,
but they also might intelligent and you
might be able to like sort it out.
Let me parse out what your thoughts are
and see where I differ and how you got
to where you got and maybe they'll have
a better understanding of your
philosophy and.
But there's a lot of people that don't
even have a philosophy.
It is,
it sounds good.
So they just go with this predetermined
pattern that's easy to follow as a left
wing.
Progressive.
I feel this,
I mean,
I've heard people say that before,
like as a Democrat,
I've always felt like,
oh,
we as a demo.
How about as a fucking person that's.
No,
it's not.
It's,
um,
ideas are hard,
you know,
thoughts on life and how we cohabitate
and how we move through this fucking
existence together.
It's very difficult to work out.
We were just so many variables,
so many styles of human,
you know,
there's just so many different things
that we have to work through together
and to try to,
to try to do that based on patterns that
other people have established and that
you cannot break and then,
you know,
have these.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons why it's so
ruthless to say that all white people
have some implicit biases that they may
or not,
may not even be aware of.
And this,
uh,
you know,
unintended racism,
flavors,
all conversations like this,
poisoning this conversation,
you're poisoning this conversation
within a fucking fishing line.
It's all tangled up there.
Now we're going to have to figure out
what is real and pull us apart and get
it back on the spool.
No.
Yeah.
And there's no solution for some of
those too where you just say there's
some boogeyman man type thing that's
controlling all of this and there's some
conspiracy that we can't really see and
we can't point out specific examples,
but it's ever present.
And I,
I think,
yeah,
a lot of the treating people as
individuals that has become more of a
libertarian thing.
Yeah.
And so it's hard to,
at least for me to understand some of
this more collective thinking and social
conformity,
which I've never been a fan of.
But
do you think it was a good idea to write
that memo?
Like if you had to go back again,
if you were in front of your computer
and you're ready press,
would you uh,
maybe I would wait for my year end bonus
man.
I mean I think I would have pushed
harder,
even harder on the diversity programs,
although like I met with them personally
and I kept pinging them and I sent so
many emails.
I'm just trying to have a discussion
about this.
And I went through multiple programs and
sent this document,
this exact document to them.
So it's really unclear what I could've
done differently,
but I,
I,
for example,
I didn't know so much about the
underground conservative network before
all of this.
At Google you mean?
Yeah.
And even within silicon valley,
like there's attempts to sort of connect
them between companies,
but there's so much verification that
you need to go through to be able to
join one of these.
You have to have a pseudonym.
Uh,
I mean you don't need to be totally
anonymous,
but you know,
you,
you don't want because there's active
attempts to try to infiltrate these
groups.
Really.
Yeah.
I,
this happens a lot where they'll try to
join a group act as if they're one of
them and then just,
you know,
record what's happening and then expose
them
and you know,
you can take anything out of context and
it would be shown as you know,
racism or something.
Sure.
What mean.
Think of what we said,
well,
not you but me joking around in this
conversation.
You could clearly take something I've
said out of context and make my monster,
but if you're in an email and you're
complaining about some sort of diversity
program.
Yeah,
like what they often do is they will
find someone that they disagree with and
then they'll scour through their entire
history at Google and all of the emails
that they've signed and try to look for
some way to blacklist them or show that
this person is evil,
therefore they should be fired.
Oh,
it's horrible.
And supposedly this is happening in
other companies too,
and they even have like these automated
scripts to try to find these negative
things on people that they don't like.
Wow.
So a little little psychological covert
warfare.
Yeah.
And that's also going to contribute to
people towing the line.
Right.
They don't want to keep their job.
Like look at you just said maybe you
would have waited until you got your
year end bonus people.
I mean,
and you are a single guy,
right?
Yeah.
So family,
that definitely helped where I don't
have as many responsibilities.
I imagine if he did,
you know,
you probably wouldn't have said anything
you had thought about it and go,
you know what,
I have to worry about my family and
taking care of my bills and
so weird band.
Yeah.
I mean the worst part is these people
think that they're doing the right
thing,
right?
Like censoring people and finding these
people is the right thing because any of
those people are wrong.
Yeah.
So that's how they think.
They think,
okay,
I have everyone sees the world the same.
Therefore anyone that disagrees with me
is either misinformed or a misogynist
bigot.
Right.
Otherwise,
how could I have possibly said those
things?
Yeah.
When really,
you know,
I,
people with different political
ideologies see the world differently and
they have different biases and you know,
none of them are totally correct,
but we need to be able to discuss
things,
to show,
you know,
a more objective view of the world
without a doubt.
The fact that that is even up for debate
is a very strange.
I mean,
that's an ideological echo chamber and
that seems like for whatever reason that
seems like where a tech is and that's
where technology companies seem to lean
towards this very left wing ideological
echo chamber.
Yeah.
And I mean I saw it a lot too on the
comments of a document where I said,
Oh yeah,
these are just biases.
And no,
they were like,
no,
the right is indoctrinated.
They're just KKK and there
anti-education they're anti poor people.
They're anti everything,
like not all of them.
And yet at least the way I see it and
not being,
you know,
total conservative.
I can't necessarily say,
but it seems like they don't necessarily
hate poor people or anything.
They just think that these certain
incentive structures are what's best for
society and you know,
it's not best to promote or they think
that some things will lead to laziness
or something.
And that's not saying,
Oh yeah,
these people are just horrible people.
They actually want to help everyone.
And they think that these,
uh,
social norms and government programs may
be hurting people.
Yeah,
I mean there certainly are some people
that are right wing that think like that
and then there's some people that are
right wing that are really racist.
Yeah.
And they,
they exist too and there's some people
that are left wing that are really
racist and they're really racist towards
white people.
I mean,
that's,
that's there's white people that are
racist towards white people.
I mean,
I've read so many fucking tweets from
people that,
you know,
like I've,
I follow a bunch of anti social justice
warrior accounts and they'll find people
that tweet like really horrible shit
about white people that are white.
It's like I get what you're doing,
just try to get those Brownie points,
trying to try super hard to get people
of color to love you.
And you know,
as an ally,
it's just very strange time.
I think a lot of it has to do with this
new found ability to communicate that
just really did not exist in the past.
If you wanted to get controversial ideas
past,
uh,
you know,
two massive groups of people in the
past,
you had to write a book or you had to
get an article published,
you had to be some sort of a major media
distribution center,
had to take your work and put it out
there for the people.
Now that's not the case,
so now you get a lot of,
like really fragile or really poorly
thought out ideas and uh,
as long as you can hit the nerve of
enough retards,
you can get those things out.
And then they start promoting.
I mean,
that's where the flat earth movement is
coming from.
What does that,
other than that,
I mean,
that's exactly what it is.
It's enough people that just don't have
a sense of the importance of critical
thinking skills or are not used to
objectives,
assessing ideas.
And then they,
they coalesce in these groups that are
likeminded and you can get that with
racism.
You can get that with sexism.
You can get that with pretty much
anything,
right?
You get these likeminded groups,
they get together and they have
confirmation bias and they get an
ideological echo chamber and they start
reinforcing each other,
you know?
Yeah,
and definitely.
I mean it affects who you follow and you
just assume,
oh yeah,
everyone thinks like this,
therefore it must be.
Right.
Yeah,
and I mean it's really a shame though,
that this is happening even in the
pursuit of knowledge in academia where
so many people,
how a certain worldview,
like the social sciences have 90 percent
of people lean left.
Yeah.
And that's,
that can create its own confirmation
biases and especially when you know
it's,
it's definitely bad like in tech where
20 percent of people are women and they
can feel alienated,
but at least no overt signs of sexism
are seen as bad.
Right.
But over signs of discriminating against
people based on their political
orientation is seen as okay and people
do it.
And so yeah,
there's a big asymmetry there where you
actually feel it's justified to.
Maybe it wouldn't be as big of an issue
if we had a reasonable republican
president.
Maybe if we had someone who was really
kind and rational,
Mitt Romney type who seemed like far
more reasonable and you know,
it's
sort of,
you know,
I mean,
wow,
we have a bunch of issues obviously as a
country now with this guy is president
and I think that we're also dealing with
a really young,
an infant stage of information
distribution.
Like a,
the ability for anyone to mass
distribute anything is.
So like anyone can create a,
a,
you know,
a youtube video and if it strikes a cord
it can hit a million people like that
this time like that before where,
you know,
I mean,
and the incentive structures are all out
of whack where it's better to be
outrageous than it is to be honest.
And that that's causing a lot of our
headlines to just be,
you know,
oh,
he starts a sexist and there's no room
for nuance,
but it'll also don't,
you think that it's,
there's a lack of time that people have.
Just like I told you how much time I
spent going over your stuff.
And and after awhile I was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I think it would work in tech,
but most people don't have that kind of
time.
Nor do they have that sort of obsessive
mindset.
They look at the surface of something,
oh,
this guy wrote a sexist memo about women
in tech.
Fuck him.
It's probably a misogynist,
and they just marched towards their
meeting and we have to avoid the kind of
thinking that lead to someone thinking
that it's okay to write the Google memo
and then everyone like,
yes,
here I want my year end bonus.
I think as the dust settles we will get
more and more truth out of people.
And I think there's a general trend with
information to,
to have information be easier and easier
to distribute.
That's the one of the most important
things about technology,
right?
They're instantaneous access to
information and right now that
information is not entirely verifiable.
Like some of it is and some of it's not.
And that's one of the more disturbing
things about people reprinting your memo
without citations.
I was like,
Hey,
like you fuckers,
you left out a big part of what this is
like,
what you did is really wrong.
Um,
those citations,
maybe people won't go into them.
Maybe they won't read the studies.
Maybe they won't let me,
it takes a long time if you really want
to get involved in that,
but there will be a better version of
that in the future of.
I think they will.
I think.
I think that's where the,
I mean obviously I don't know,
but I think that's where the trend is.
I think the trend is leaning towards
more and more honest interpretation of
facts and ideas and then you know,
we'll be left with some,
some things that we have to look at that
we can't just write off to sociology or
write off to culture or off to biases or
sexism or racism.
We're going to have to look at things
for what they really are and maybe we'll
have a better understanding of why we
behave the way we do,
why we have the problems that we have.
Yeah.
And part of the issue though is if
someone controls the access to
information and they want a certain area
to be told,
then you know,
it'll really color what people see.
And that's what's scary.
And you know,
we see this a lot on youtube now where
they're demonetizing anyone that they
see as right wing and no even censoring
and removing videos.
It's really scary.
It is.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
I mean it's,
it's,
uh,
it's quite fascinating to watch it all
play out and to have them do it like
right in front of everybody's face.
And everybody goes,
what are you doing like you are,
you're changing narratives.
You're altering information.
And they feel like they are right.
They're doing the right thing.
They're promoting diversity.
They're promoting liberal values and
progressive ideas and they think they're
doing the right thing.
Don't necessarily think they're right
though,
you know,
it's just a lot of blow back though.
I mean,
this is not free.
It's not free ride for Google right now
with what they've done to you.
I mean,
I'm sure there's been,
I'm sure they're doubling down because
they don't want to admit they're fucked
up.
If they admit they're fucked up,
everybody across the board loses that
year end bonus becomes a real issue,
right?
Everybody gets fired.
But if they,
uh,
you know,
if you look at it long term over the
long run,
I mean they have definitely taken a hit
and if someone forces them to sit down,
I would love to sit down with the guy
who said that you promote harmful gender
stereotypes and go,
let's go,
let's go to this thing.
Step by step.
You tell me what's wrong and just pick
them apart.
That's what I've always wanted.
But he'll fall apart 100 percent.
I just say a bunch of stupid social
justice warrior bullshit.
And if you just keep them in a room for
three hours of the microphone,
it's going to look like a fucking idiot.
Just no way around it.
You know?
There's no way around it.
If you're just active,
if you actually going off of what you
wrote to somehow or another,
I think it's very not just dangerous to
say it promotes harmful gender
stereotypes.
It's disingenuous.
And why?
The reason why it's dangerous is because
I could just read what that guy said and
I would think that you're a creep and
that's dangerous to you.
It's dangerous towards the marketplace
of free ideas.
The marketplace of ideas is extremely
important and I would think that if
anybody would know that it would be the
people that are involved in tech,
you would think so?
Yeah.
I mean they're just so wrapped up just
so wrapped up in the progressive
mindset.
It's weird,
man.
It's circulated to all this
microaggression.
Speech is violence and yeah,
all ideas are harmful and,
and of course some ideas are harmful,
but it's only through openly discussing
them.
Can you actually dispel some of these
things by making them,
you know,
forbidding knowledge that's only going
to attract certain people and you know,
we even see this now worth some of the
youtube videos that are in this
purgatory type state where you know,
you can't really get to them,
but if you know the url,
you can still find that people are
getting aggregated lists of those and
actually viewing them and oh,
this is what youtube doesn't want us to
see.
Maybe there's some truth to it.
Why don't they want them to see it?
Yeah.
If you win a certain amount of money,
are you willing to buy a gold plated
Ferrari and drive around with a fur
coat?
Because I think that Kinda Shit.
Big Ass crazy sunglasses,
a win.
I don't really know.
And I mean I'm trying to.
I mean what I would ideally want and
somehow changing their policies,
but I don't really know how I as an
individual can compel google to do
something like that.
But I think at least some of the stuff
like the blacklisting where they have
these people that,
you know,
compile these spreadsheets of names of
people that are conservative or even
Libertarian and Oh,
we're not going to work with them,
we're going to sabotage their work and
we're going to try to get them fired
when they are looking for another job.
We're going to share this list so they
can't get hired from any of the
other major companies like that needs
to.
That's real.
Yeah.
How do you know that?
That's real to have you seen this list
yet?
So there've been multiple people that
have admitted to having a blacklist.
Wow.
I libertarian,
not even conservative,
not even right wing,
but smaller government libertarian.
Yeah.
Just because,
I mean it's generally free thinking,
people not telling the party line and
those people get blacklisted really.
If there's an actual list somewhere.
I think if you've seen an actual list.
I haven't seen an individual list.
I think there's multiple lists spread
out,
but people even like high up managers
have admitted to having a car,
a blacklist.
Wow.
And you know,
we have brought this up to the highest
people at Google and they just
completely dismissed it,
like we're not going to deal with it.
So do you feel like they feel that they
have some sort of a social
responsibility to push progressive
values because they're in this massive
position of influence and they feel like
that's the right way to think.
So they're going to go full steam ahead.
Yeah.
And don't be evil.
Don't be conservative.
Pretty much the libertarian man.
Boy,
so fucking tough sell to say that Gary
Johnson's evil,
you know?
I don't know.
But yeah,
it's,
it's really hard to understand that
mindset.
But yeah,
I get it though because I think it's a
lot of the same things along the same
lines that you were talking about when
you were saying that you didn't,
you know,
like maybe you would have waited till
you got your year end bonus and you're a
guy who is also a frugal.
You've saved your money and you don't
have a family to support and you're
okay.
You know,
you got fired and you're still okay.
You know.
Whereas some people will be fucked right
now.
Maybe they'd be over extended,
maybe they have that goal,
Ferrari and the fur coat and shit.
Yeah,
I mean if I had a mortgage or something
scary,
that's where it gets scary.
That's a lot of people's decision
making.
I mean that's,
that goes back to you know,
engineering civilization and the early
days of Rome.
I think there was writings about that,
about getting people to commit to
families and it's easier to control them
when they have other ones and,
and you know,
and things that they enjoy and positions
of power and status that it's easier to
get those people to give into your needs
and desires.
Yeah,
I mean it makes sense,
right?
I mean it's just engineering a
civilization.
It's one of the like getting people to
perform and behave the way that you
would like them to is a critical
component of engineering.
Any sort of civilization and is
essentially a civilization if you look
at it that way.
I mean internally there's a is a
community.
It's a structure and their engineering
that structured to be very a likeminded
ideological echo chamber
and I think it's really going to bite
them in the back at some point,
like they're making the easy decision of
not really facing the,
you know,
the truth as I see it.
And you know,
if you turn your back on that for too,
too long,
it's really going to have negative
consequences later.
Yeah.
Well I,
I feel like one thing it's super
important to point out,
I think we kind of already did,
but women do experience a lot of sexism.
And again,
it's because like I said,
men are gross.
You know,
there's a lot of gross men and men
working in close proximity with women.
I mean men working with other men,
they're going to find things they don't
like about those men.
Yeah,
I mean people have interpersonal
relationships are fucking gross and
messy and if men work with women and
they feel like they can dominate them
with aggression or with some sort of
weird tactics that play on the
agreeableness,
females tend to have the,
you know,
it's,
it's a problem.
And I think by not looking at it that by
not being honest about that,
we do just as much as of a disservice.
Yeah.
Although,
I mean,
I would say that there are men that are
just as agreeable and just as much of a
pushover say yeah,
sure.
And they also get a Shandan aside and
sometimes it's even worse for men that
fit that stereotype or don't fit the
typical male stereotype because you
know,
there's negative consequences on both
sides for not being masculine if you're
a man or not being feminine enough if
you're a woman.
Yeah.
Like you're not allowed to just be
yourself.
Right?
You have to like fit why you're better
off.
You fit into some sort of a classic
narrative.
Yeah.
So where do you go from here?
Besides sue?
In the form of Google.
Google.
Just give them some money to shut him
out.
Do you want to go through with a
lawsuit?
Like what if they came to you with a
settlement?
Would you just take it and shut your
mouth?
I don't.
I really want somehow for them to
address it,
but I don't know how to do
well.
Even if they,
if you lose in court,
will they address it?
They'll probably say,
you know,
although we support the court,
we disagree with the rulings and we
still support gender equality and yet,
I mean,
I think part of it is that there is
currently an asymmetry.
So maybe Google is acting in their best
interest to act the way that they are
because they think that,
you know,
there's all these activists that are
trying to attack Google that only if
they don't fit this summer.
Are there a lot of activists that are
attacking Google in that regard?
Yeah.
And you know,
we even see that there's now a potential
class action lawsuit against Google
about war,
a gender pay disparity and so like they
just are looking for anything.
And if we say that if there's only
incentive coming from one side,
then only going to push farther and
farther to that side.
And this gender pay disparity is just
involving similar jobs yet.
So they claim that it's the same job.
Although at least when Google was doing
their own internal analysis,
which they've been doing for years,
they show that there's no disparity once
you control for pay for performance,
and so it's really unclear and,
but you control for performance
performance tends to favor
males.
Maybe I if,
if that's what they're showing,
that there is some sort of gender
disparity.
If you just look at aggregate,
look at this one in $100,
million chance,
alleged gender pay gap at Google is
random.
Says class action lawyer.
Oh Jesus class action lawyer says that
in the article is written by a chick
fake fake news.
You're not going to get me.
You fucks.
I think one thing is I don't think that
they really have Google's internal data,
so there's no way for them to say
whether or not it's based on performance
liquid there.
They're saying here,
you know,
notices seeking women currently or
formerly employed at Google for possible
inclusion in a planned class action
lawsuit.
First of all,
people hear that and they're like,
we're going to get paid.
Well,
go Sizzla,
right?
I mean,
that's just.
You're playing on human instincts when
you seek out people that may have been
employed for a possible inclusion in a
class action lawsuit.
That's not saying that they weren't
wronged because I don't obviously,
I don't know,
several dozen came forward in a matter
of weeks.
That's a pretty high level of
dissatisfaction.
Says James Feinberg.
No,
it's not.
there's fucking thousands of people
who've worked there and a couple dozen
came forward.
That's not a high level of satisfaction.
How many people have been employed at
Google that are no longer employed?
It's probably tens of thousands,
right?
Yeah.
There's 70,000
people here.
Okay,
so for this guy to say,
that's a pretty high level of
dissatisfaction when several dozen,
let's say three dozen.
Let's go crazy.
Let's say it's 40 people.
Let's get nuts.
That's fucking nobody man.
Oh,
70 women.
It's biggest heard from.
But wait a minute,
hurt from it doesn't mean they might not
even make sense.
That might not be a case for four people
for.
That's not a lot.
You fuck the class action.
I mean that's just.
This is.
This is a fucking ambulance chaser
Chaser,
right?
I mean,
I'm not saying he's wrong,
I'm not saying there's not sexual
discrimination,
but I'm saying like this,
these articles are sneaky as fuck shock
for people.
You got four people and I don't know how
an individual would know whether or not
they're paid differently just based on
their sex.
Right?
Because there's so many variables at
play,
so you really have to look at the system
as a whole because I mean there are
definitely some men that are paid less
than the women too for performance was
like that.
The problem is when you control for
performance,
if it turns out that men are being paid
more than you have to figure out some
sort of a way to justify that.
Or you know,
like if men are being paid more when you
control for performance,
what is it that's causing the men to be
paid more?
Why are they performing better because
of the environment they feel more
comfortable.
Is it lack of suppression that the women
experience like.
Yeah.
So I guess when you look at the
nationwide gender gap in pay where you
know even Obama has said seventy seven
cents per dollar is too little.
Yeah,
but he's a silly person.
Like I shouldn't have done that.
Like he,
he knows.
Like when Obama said that,
he knows that that's not being honest
because you're talking about completely
different jobs,
different choices for people don't know.
Okay,
let's just break that down real quick.
This thing,
because people repeated ad nauseum and
it's just not true.
The gender pay gap of seventy seven
cents to a dollar that a male makes is
based on the choices that people make as
far as like what they do for a living.
It's based on the amount of hours that
they work.
Men tend to work longer hours.
Women tend,
especially if they get pregnant.
All those things are factored in.
That's where you get seventy seven cents
on average for the dollar that the male
makes.
What it implies,
and this is where it's disingenuous
because it two people working side by
side doing the same job and the males
getting 77 more a dollar for the woman's
seventy seven cents.
That's not what the gender pay gap
actually means.
And if Google is actually,
if someone is saying if there's a
lawsuit that's saying that a man and a
woman are doing the exact same job with
the exact same performance and the woman
is only getting seventy seven cents on
the dollar,
then you got a real issue.
Right?
Yeah.
And so it's often or that you know,
there's different hours worked and it
doesn't even have to be that,
you know,
they work twice as many or 30 percent
more.
It's sometimes if you just work 44 hours
a week versus 34 hours or something,
then there's a huge,
a pay disparity.
Yeah.
And that's irrespective of what gender
you have.
It's just,
especially at Google,
there was so much time that was just,
you know,
replying to email and doing some base
level stuff,
going to meetings and then you only had
a little bit that was actually creative
and providing value to the company.
Really.
Yeah.
So it was really inefficient in that
regard.
Right.
And you know,
it's similar in a lot of companies do so
and that creates some of this,
you know,
nonlinear,
uh,
benefits of working just a little more
per week and you know,
we see this a lot in silicon valley
where there's a lot of people right out
of college and they're willing to work
a ton of time especially,
you know,
you can essentially live at Google.
So there's not,
I mean,
yeah,
there's free food everywhere.
There's showers,
there's a gem.
The beds,
there is nap pods.
Pods,
yeah.
Wow.
Are they closed off?
She can,
can't hear anything out there.
But can you actually step in there?
Good.
I can't really sleep in there just
because I'm too tall,
but most people,
yeah,
you can sleep in there because some they
like close it off and you could just lay
there.
Um,
is there a term for a being being
discriminary discriminatory towards tall
people?
Yeah.
Tallest.
Hightest.
Yeah.
I just like,
there's able lists,
right?
There's a few mock people that aren't
able to do things.
You become an herbalist.
There's definitely a movement now of
looking into.
Oh,
maybe tell people have some advantages
because we see that a lot of ceos are
over six feet tall and it's not clear
why exactly that is.
I knew you really have to control for
every aspect because there is no
correlation between height and
intelligence,
but it's likely not just that,
you know,
but what I'm saying is like they're
discriminating against you with the
pots.
Hook your fucking seven,
like six,
four,
six,
three hook you up with a six for pod
man.
We can stretch your legs out and get a
good nap.
Maybe it'd be more productive at a job
you don't work out anymore.
I guess I just never really felt like
complaining too much.
Good for you.
Except for that one thing.
One thing.
So,
um,
are you trying to seek other employment
or are you.
Yeah,
I'm still looking at,
you know,
what exactly I want to do because I
never was,
you know,
coding wasn't the thing that I was doing
my entire life.
Is that what your education is in?
No,
so I was doing physics and biology,
random mass stuff and I just picked up
some algorithm books and they seemed
really cool.
So I started doing some coding
competitions and I did well enough that
Google just like randomly contacted me.
Wow.
How weird.
And especially since you're a white
male,
back in the day before they figured out
discriminate here,
this was all online then I had a
username so maybe they didn't know.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So they contacted you and offering you
employment based on your coding skills?
Yeah,
that's weird.
Oh,
that's cool.
So,
um,
so now you're just trying to figure out
what the next.
How old are you?
Twenty eight.
So he's telling you very young man,
you got to figure out what the path is
going to be.
Huh?
Yeah.
You're leaning one way or another,
uh,
something that uses my brain,
but yeah,
that'd be nice.
Something outside of tech maybe or what
navy or I still feel like,
you know,
tech in general is or the future and
will have huge impact on the world.
So something related to tech,
but maybe not coding all day,
but I really don't know because,
you know,
most of the major silicon valley jobs
probably a blacklisted me.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's unfortunate man.
Um,
because like I said,
I've read your memo.
I don't think you did anything wrong.
I think you did.
You took a bold choice and a bold stance
to talk about something that's
essentially taboo,
but you did it with science,
you know,
and you did it.
It didn't,
you didn't a very reasonable manner.
You know,
and I'm,
I'm shocked at the reaction has been as
extreme as it's been,
but I'm not shocked at the same time.
Right.
I mean,
it's predictable almost.
And the people calling you a massage
nest.
It was very weird and CEO of youtube
saying it hurt her to read that,
like,
you're going to have a real life yet.
I mean,
I thought that,
you know,
the first,
the intro which talked about all these
political biases and how our culture
shames people that give a different
view.
I thought that might have shown that,
you know,
maybe we shouldn't be doing that,
but you know,
predicted exactly what happened to me.
I think very few people actually read it
probably.
Yeah.
Especially like globally,
very few people.
It's a very bad.
I think,
you know,
the responses to it,
a very click baity and people go with
whatever the titles of the articles that
are criticizing you and just accept that
as Gospel,
you know?
Yeah.
I've gotten a lot of responses that were
just,
Oh yeah,
I saw it on facebook,
you know,
some sexist memo.
And it was only after they saw that so
many times and they decided to read it,
but they finally were like,
oh no,
it's not that bad.
Yeah.
I urge people,
if you have the time,
just please just read it.
Just go over it and try to figure out
where it all went wrong.
I'm glad you did it though,
man.
I mean,
it's a really interesting point of
discussion and I hope this lawsuit works
out well for you.
And I helped Google just come to their
senses and I don't think that's going to
happen,
you know?
What do you predict?
What do you think's going to happen?
I don't know.
I think that people now are aware of
this a lot more and there may be
platforms that emerge that are sort of
all tech is what they're calling it.
Just alternative technology that's more
open to just free speech.
But unfortunately they're currently just
being labeled as white supremacist sites
and you know,
it's,
I,
hopefully people can see through that.
I don't know if they have the time to
even look.
That's the thing.
It's just like they're,
they're taking everyone's word for
everything.
It's very odd time,
but there's enough people discussing it,
you know,
and I think your,
um,
the response to your memo has been,
it's been very enlightening for some
people from,
from a sort of a psychological
standpoint.
Like what,
what are the reactions that people have
and why do they have these reactions and
what is it,
what does it say about us as human
beings at this is such a taboo subject
that we can't even address the very real
differences that we have as unique
individuals.
You know,
I'm at least happy that it didn't happen
during a college season is then there'd
be like protests and people burning my
fig years and things.
So I think it would have been a much
more negative if it was during the
school year.
Wow.
And they would demand that their school,
you know,
double down on diversity and just all of
these things.
But yeah,
a lot of virtue signaling going on.
It's at least it's nice to see some of
the colleges have been standing up for
it or against it and you know,
saying,
no,
you can't really just tell us what to
do.
And we believe in,
you know,
knowledge and actually seeking the truth
and not just criticizing people based on
their political ideologies.
Yeah,
it's a long slog.
My friend.
It was a lot,
a lot of walking and talking and going
on,
but uh,
I think it will be fun.
I hope I hope will be fine if we don't
go to war with North Korea and get
smashed by 100 fucking hurricanes in a
row.
Um,
but I think we should just got to tweak
that.
You're a bad ass in chess.
Chess master.
Yeah.
I played a lot of just,
yeah,
that,
that was my life for a few years.
Can you play chess in your head?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
I used to play chess in my head against
like for different people.
So like blindfolded.
Whoa,
dude.
I knew this kid who was a chess master
and a pool hall that he used to go to
and he used to play with this ex con and
the ex con learned how to do chest and
prison,
uh,
in his head with no pieces and him and
this kid would just sit there and play
chess back and forth with each other.
Now what are you guys doing?
How do you know where the board is?
You could play it blindfolded with four
people in your head.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's intense man.
How'd you learn how to do that?
Just repetition over time.
Yeah,
doing it a lot and just obsessing over
it.
And this is actually one of the
differences on average between men and
women is there are more men that are
just become obsessed with these systems
and so,
you know,
magic.
The gathering,
the card game was also something that I
became super obsessed with.
And so the way that people approach
computers too is different where you
know,
some are a lot of boys just approach the
computer as a toy and they become
obsessed with tinkering with the
computer while a lot girls see it as
a tool for improving the world and so
they may not be interested in the
computer as an end to itself.
And so a lot of the education programs
to get more women into tech are actually
addressing that.
But it's unclear because so much of a
coding is just,
you know,
writing server code and this server is
going to go talk to this server which is
talking to that server and it's totally
unconnected to actual people and,
but you know,
that's why we actually see more women in
front end and use your experience,
um,
engineering positions because it's more
interactive with people.
What are the numbers with women in
chess?
Yeah,
there aren't that many.
And it's unfortunate.
I,
is it unfortunate because it's just,
it is.
Yeah.
I don't play chess is that
unfortunately.
So why is it unfortunate that women are
underrepresented?
Well,
just for the cases of maybe they feel
like a minority and you a right and a
lot of the mistreatment of women is not
ill intentioned men that want to be
sexist against men.
It's just,
I and I felt this a lot and you know,
everyone wants a girl to play chess or
play magic.
The gathering,
you know that that's their ideal
girlfriend.
So,
and,
but they're all nerdy guys are generally
and they don't have as good social
skills as the average population.
And you know,
they're pretty similar to the people
playing or a writing code,
so it's a similar situation so they just
don't know how to interact with women
and that causes some problems.
But,
so it's not the just overt sexism
against women,
it's more just we don't really know how
to interact with women,
we just,
you know,
we're obsessed with jazz or whatever and
we just like talking about chess and
there are a lot of women that just
aren't as obsessed with these sort of
systems.
So.
But I mean that's not a bad thing,
right?
It just is what it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure there's a bunch of fashion
things and aesthetics thing,
et Cetera,
aesthetic things and design things that
women are really into that a lot of men
don't give a fuck about.
Yeah.
It's not a terrible thing that men
aren't into design does not more men
involved in interior design.
It's not a terrible thing.
And that's sort of one of the
unfortunate thing is too,
is that there's so much fighting to get
more women into tech,
but there's no fighting to get more men
into nursing.
Right.
Any of these more female dominated.
Do you think that's also because of the
financial rewards of tech are so extreme
in comparison,
like nursing is pretty kept salary.
Whereas if you can climb the corporate
ladder as a,
you know,
a ceo of some sort of a tech company,
the rewards are substantial.
Yeah.
I think inevitably there will be more
men attracted to high paying jobs simply
because they fight for status and money
is how you gain status often.
So that's partly why they see tech as a
target,
but it's not as if nursing is a bad job
that gets paid well.
And there are many people that,
you know,
go to college for premed and dropout,
like 90 percent of people that started
as premed dropout.
And the men feel like they can't enter
nursing because that's too feminine.
And there's huge biases against men
becoming feminine.
Like,
you know,
man can't wear dresses,
but girls can be openly tomboyish.
Right?
Right.
So there's unfortunately some
asymmetries in our culture and there's
reasons for it.
You know,
if a guy is too feminine,
then he can't necessarily fulfill his
gender role,
which is being a provider and protector.
Uh,
so,
you know,
you have to be aggressive to be a good
protector and provider for your wife.
But,
uh,
the females gender role being a nurturer
is,
you know,
it's fine to be feminine and so a lot of
the gender disparities that we see and
gender norms are just a but behind those
two gender roles.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
there's a lot of evidence to support
that and I think,
um,
that was essentially a big part of what
you were talking about in your memo and
I don't think you're a bad guy dude,
and I think you've been unfairly
maligned and uh,
I'm glad we had a chance to sit down and
talk and uh,
and uh,
I wish you well man.
I hope it all works out and keep us
posted and we'll let everybody else know
too.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you James.
Appreciate it,
man.
Very nice to meet you.
Thank you.
All right folks.
Say for today.
Bye.
How long was that?
Almost three hours.